all right and we are finally
live in 2021
hello and welcome to the last word with
ebatis
back at the campfire man it feels like i
haven't seen
you or talked to you in ages it feels
too long
but we got a special guest going on
today too first of all what's going on
man
man like for those of you guys who have
been following me my internet has given
me hell
we got through the crazy podcast adobe
kitty cat the four hour beast episode
but it was a good one because we had a
month off
and everything seems to have happened in
destiny the community's got a whole lot
of stuff that's going on
and my internet felt like just crapping
out so i've had four texts in my house
i've had two new cable modems
a line at a node had a crack in it
everything's gone wrong with my internet
but at this point cross our fingers
things seem okay knock on all the wood
you can
and at this point uh i've been playing a
bunch of other stuff we'll talk about
all these things but
we've got a guest waiting in the wings
so cognito back to you
let's introduce them as we only know how
do this thing 2021
welcome to the last word episode number
132.
it's a glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose passion
for the destiny franchise and the titan
class
is only matched by his dedication to
bodybuilding and creating a positive
atmosphere
on twitter and instagram
introducing the in real life titan main
and owner of the most hilarious video
skits on the ground
our fellow fitness lord of iron who
remains yot and obsessed
but will still find a way to sneak some
ice cream in on
cheat day live from texas
and making his debut at the campfire of
the last
word ramen lord i
r l titan how you doing sir i'm doing
great thanks for having me gentlemen
absolutely
let's do it long overdue man how you
been brother
been busy very busy as
are we all at the start of this
interesting year
oh you say the least yeah this year has
been
kicking off uh hit the ground running to
say the least not a slow beginning
apparently it's just gonna try and
compete with last year which was
a whole mess in itself but um yeah i
know
we we know you well from like twitter
and stuff like that we know this man is
out here grinding like level 700 on the
season pass because he loves bounty
knockouts
but i but before we even get there like
man you are
in some amazing shape and it's something
definitely hard worked on good to be
proud of
um i just wanted to ask you first when
it comes to that
i saw your kind of progression there's a
pic of you
look definitely younger i don't know the
age of it the comparison between the two
when did you decide to go from like i've
got some muscles to like
to the next level when did you decide to
take it to where you are now like how
how did that progression happen to be
like i'm gonna be fit to
i'm gonna be a beast so i really there
was
almost no choice for the progression
at about 10 years old my dad got me
my older brother and my little brother
when each of us turned 10 started in the
garage
we trained for six years straight before
we told him we wanted to go to the gym
he said if we passed a pt test that we
had 90 days to
prepare for i'll buy y'all a membership
wherever you want and the rest is
history
currently going on 18 straight years
worth of training
now he said you had like pt
oh he wasn't playing with joe this is on
monday through friday
5 a.m even when he deployed mama bear
got us up
wow
[Music]
this is just kind of always been
something that
i've done it became so ingrained in me
and my brother's dna that we just
all we did it you emulate the things you
see
and we saw both of our parents just
tearing it up in the gym
there was no way we weren't gonna get
into it i wasn't gonna be like dad i
wanna
i think i just wanna be an artist he
would have been like all right here's
this dumbbell or here's a 400 pound
weight brush
if you can lift that you can bang go
ahead
definitely the dedication and discipline
from young
you see that travel now also staying on
this bodybuilding kick like
the other thing that we see you do is
with the nutrition you're really
really good about that eating clean like
tell me about how you
started to kind of incorporate that or
also help others with nutrition
yeah so that kind of came once i got a
little bit further into it
and just you know you start working out
and you
you you really realize how important the
nutrition is almost right out of the
gate if you're meant to get into it and
that was just kind of the same deal is
my parents constantly they didn't have
sodas or snacks or anything like that or
we'd come home
and we'd have celery and peanut butter
chopped chicken
you know just stuff that was already
pre-made so we didn't question it we
just came home it was there you can get
moving
but i went to school and got a
bachelor's in nutritional science i went
through another program and became an
rd and just you and nutrition is so
integral to everything that happens in
your body that if you get it going right
you you feel better you know the looks
and all that aside you know that's
really not part of it and that's not
part of it that i like to focus on
ever because i know plenty of people
that on paper or in a photo you'd go man
that dude's huge he looks great
he's probably happy my man's got
clinical depression
high blood pressure a resting heart rate
over a hundred
pre-diabetic you name it i've met him
i've trained them like
you just the the whole there's a big
disconnect between
people's health and and the aesthetics
behind it especially with the
social media and youtube and that whole
that whole side of the fitness industry
is a lot of good and a whole lot of bad
yeah i wanted to ask too is like because
for you as well it's like you have a
degree
in you know diet your dietitian you have
actual degree in there which takes that
next step because some people like
nutritionist and dietitian is like the
medical you're in hospitals doing the
help
giving people things that are going to
help them change their lives and put
them on a proper path
but for you i mean you've got an
instagram out there in your pictures
it's like
a lot of people probably in a gym would
look look at you potentially and say
that guy's taken something like
something not natural things like that
that happen
and it's like for you as long as you've
done it like yeah it's like hey it's
like as long as you've done it like
you've done this i would like naturally
but it's just like
that type of thing i know does that bug
you at all do you even care
or are there ways that you could look at
someone to be like that guy's real that
guy's fake are there certain things that
you even can
know with your background that you can
tell just kind of curious because the
look
definitely makes some people be like hey
why is why does he look like that
yeah you know no literally no matter
what you're doing
somebody somewhere is to dislike you
for if i was the best cupcake maker in
all of texas
there'd be someone on the corner like
that dude is using cheap chinese sugar
don't ever
don't you dare go buy his cupcakes
i was on youtube somebody's gonna hate
my channel
i get hate on my only fans all the time
i'm telling you it's constant
and taking it only fast huh
don't worry we'll edit that in post
anyway
savagely look definitely
you know so i i get met with a lot of
hostility from certain people
or you know working in my storefront
it's usually
hey man you look great wish i could get
on what you were on
wink wink nudge nuts a couple weeks back
i had a lady tell me i was
or how did she phrase it oh you're
smarter than you look
oh god you're like i've got a degree i
took it to another level i just
you just smile through the pain 2020
taught us a lot
of jesus we're all we're all there but
it
you know i don't really i don't mind
mostly because
for the one kid that walks up to me in
the gym
who i can tell has little to no
confidence who's really overweight
who comes up and says hey man i really
don't want to bother you but if i could
give five minutes your time
at some point email phone number
whatever just have a conversation with
you i really love to learn something
i will drop what i'm doing and give that
man every ounce of my time
for free no questions asked because
that's the person that i do it for i
don't care about joe schmoe who's over
there
ego curling weight that he can't handle
that yeah
yeah definitely you know i i don't go
out to
bars or drink because if you're a big
guy at a bar
there's always somebody somebody always
someone and i make a comment whatever
but that that whole side of things i
just
i really don't like to focus on period
and i feel like
most people that do it and are do it for
the long term
it's the exact same way
look man keep doing what you're doing
keep inspiring on that level that is
really cool
i mean i know once in a while i put up
some inspirational stuff and you always
send love and
same way with you and i it's cool to see
that kind of like i call it like the
inspirational train
and you know people are doing their
little thing whatever it is even if you
don't say you're just out there doing
cardio or whatever
you know and you see it and i love it i
think amazing other people do it to it
i love what i'm seeing because as gamers
which we're gonna get into
i think it's important i think it's
important i think it's important for us
to still prioritize
some level of fitness that's why i got
so much respect for eagles when they put
them points in that thing
he got to get back there dude he does it
you know what i said he does every time
he you know what i'm saying and you know
he's a kickboxing
kickboxing instructor and stuff like
that so it's it's cool to see this
little thing
we all got going you know i think it's
dope and see
before we move forward right there is
something especially
this time of year that i think anybody
anyone in chat anyone watching this
later
that you've gotta know if you're nervous
about walking into a gym because you
think you're gonna be judged your people
don't like you whatever
nobody cares what you're doing
half of them won't even realize you're
there and the rest of the people in
there will be rooting for you either
to your face or silently it that whole
stereotype of yeah you know it
it's all a super personal conceited
thing it's just not there i
love seeing people make progress i
wouldn't be working in the field that
i'm working in if i didn't want to see
people get healthier and succeed at
something
and i was like literally cannot
reiterate the more same thing it's like
you have people walk in the gym and the
hardest thing for them to do is try and
come
in walk in the door and be like hey i'm
curious about you know kick boxing's
where i'm at but i'm curious about fill
in the blank it does like
whether you go in a gym whether you go
anywhere else and as we were talking a
little bit before
it's like as you said the one guy in
you're in a big box gym and the one guy
who walks up and says hey
you know if you got just a couple
questions the fact that you're going to
go help in
or somebody walks in and be like you
know it's like
things haven't been great but i want to
make a change it's like you made the
hardest part you walk through the door
yup
and honestly anybody in like the classes
that i'll tell anybody
is like trust me it's like you can push
yourself as hard as you want as hard as
you're capable everybody's on a
different level
but i promise you everybody's trying to
do the same thing so don't
let anybody else put you in a world of
like oh fear
they're doing more than i they started
somewhere too and you're here
everybody's on the same level so no i
cannot
cannot support that enough because
that's same thing i deal with every day
people
like just they come in the door and
they're they're excited and nervous at
the same time because
they're like kickboxing i don't even
know if i can do it i'm like i can show
you how
just take it slow be patient i'll show
you the technique we'll get there
like i can't even do a push-up doesn't
matter i'm still going to show you how
to build up to that
and that's the thing is there's so many
people that expect one thing
and when you show them that's not how it
is it's
it's kind of eye-opening and helps
people really start sticking with it so
no it's like
i well yes 100 i was like sorry i kind
of went off a little bit there but the
way you said that it was like
100 especially as covet 19 is what at
least everybody seemed to have packed on
it's good that we all know we kind of
want to get it off so
you appreciate it same thing that's
literally what he said
it resonated because i was the same way
you know over 10
12 years ago whatever it was long time
ago
but when i you know when i stepped in i
was skinny kid 140 pounds
you know very intimidated to even walk
in there you know all these people are
bigger than me and stuff like that and i
used to put these mental blocks in my
head as to why not to go
and then you know you just go you just i
said you know what i want to improve
and then for me i would do little tricks
to get me to go i would like okay
i gotta have my music i'd have to have a
a little nice outfit a nice shirt
get the fly get [ __ ] to fly gym kicks
you know what i said
and then it's like okay i brought this
fly stuff to make me look good i feel
better about myself now
i gotta go i spent this money you know
those are the little motivation tricks i
used to do to self-motivate
and then eventually i said okay i don't
really
know how to accomplish these goals so i
just went up to a trade i'm like look
man
you know i'm new here i just want to get
started you know and we started a
routine for you know for a bunch of
months and stuff like that until i
finally got comfortable
at about whatever six months to a year
or whatever it was and then i was able
to kind of train on my own safely
you know correct form all that good
stuff and just keep my ego
out of it that's what i learned keep my
ego out of it stop looking at the dude
next to you
with all the plates and making the noise
and doing all that
just do with within your constraints
listen to your body when your body's
telling you
yo fam that's not it or we at our limit
right now stop
it's okay you gotta come back fight
another day you still get a good pump
and just going literally sometimes 110
yeah yes sometimes just about going
sometimes like you'd be tired you could
think of every excuse
legitimate excuse not to get in there
and then you
push you get in there and you're so
satisfied on the way out because you're
like you know what
is the best yeah the best sessions are
the one you didn't want to do
100 every time i mean 50
of a crappy workout is definitely better
than no workout so even if you're
right but i was like you may wake up on
the wrong side of the bed be tired and
be like dude i don't know if i have that
much energy i'm like hey just work on
your form like go
slow yeah go and that's i mean you said
it too is like ego it's like
we were joking before we got started
like people like trying to do bicep
curls and using them i'm like
i don't want to say it because i'm sure
he's going to say say the same thing but
i was going to ask you is like
if you have like one tip for people who
are starting to work out
the ego would probably be the biggest
thing is just start small and learn
how to do it right and don't judge
yourself
over like hey i should i'm a guy i
should be doing bicep curls with more
i'm like
there are guys that all meet in the gym
they'll come and they don't have a lot
of muscle on them they're lean but they
don't have a lot i'm like
start small doesn't matter so i was like
just do it
right and try and find the right form is
probably the first thing i'd say
fitness at the last word yeah well i
mean granted into the podcast you guys
make me do workouts in here so we might
as well start it that way for one with
this guy
right what i was to jump into is um
just how i kind of came across you was
um i forgot it was just like
i came across on twitter whatever and
i'm like who's this doing to gsc with
the funny skits
that's not what you're talking to
yourself and i'm just sitting here dying
the whole time
so i was just i wanted to get at you
with that just like how did that whole
thing start
you know you would incorporate destiny
you would incorporate you know gaming
sometimes we fitness just fun
random things cause like you remind me
to do that i would actually go to the
gnc and be like your fan when i need
this
i got that protein whatever you know so
like how did that start i was able to do
that
man i just i part boredom and
and just part personality man i'm manic
like i gotta be doing something i gotta
have my mind focused on something
when i see something that's going down
i'm just
i don't know how i have a conversation
in my head when i zone out when
someone's telling me all the excuses
that they got
for why they're not doing this or that
i'm like man
this would make a great video
you just know how to you pull from i
don't know i just kind of
i just started doing it one day man i
get bored getting these weird manic
states where i just
let's get going just think of something
get it going and why not
you know like i it's you know
that's part of my personality it's part
of who i am man like if it makes one
person laugh cool if
hundred other people hate it i don't
care i'm just gonna put it out there
if it makes me laugh i'll probably watch
it three more times
crack up by myself that's what it's
about
i love it man love it let it go
hopefully man we gotta get get that
channel going man the personalities
um zoey what's up
we gotta get this video she's been
pestering me to get one going
so it's that we all see it but without
me you were in the dms
i was like bro you're a natural you have
natural talent natural charisma you're
funny
you know what i'm saying you're doing a
cool thing you've got this game that we
love and stuff like that
you'll be surprised how many people
would really flock to it
listen to it yeah thank you see so she's
like i tell him
all the time he would be amazing i could
i could just
yell at it in all caps
you could see it bro it's it's talent
it's time but all right he doesn't what
true he's got to do it on his own to i
agree i agree but
it's there it's there and i as a content
creator i always say
i always i feel i'm good at seeing
potential in people and it's
clearly there he's saving it for the
only fans not even necessarily that i
don't want to do it it's been a slow
transition out of what i used to do so
without going into too much detail
i just spent eight years working a
government job i was traveling all over
the place
not not anywhere fun
middle east a lot all that kind of stuff
and it just i was so focused on doing
that and i never
really thought that i would stop doing
that
that when i did i'd hit the probably the
biggest wall that i've ever had to
overcome in my life
and that's how i found twitch wow as
soon as i got out i was
talking to a uh a therapist and she was
like look find
find something to to get yourself into
finding
a group or a community or something and
i came across
a video from jazz
watched one of his vids it was
absolutely hilarious popped into his
stream the next day
started you know just lurked for a while
chatting with people and then it just
exploded from there then i became really
deeply engrossed in the community that
we've got here
all the good and all the best
the roller coaster of the destination
it's kind of been
you know it's been a weird it's only
been i think it was
20 year read just turned 26 when i've
spent about two years
since i i left something i was doing for
almost a decade
you know and it was like 17 to
26 that was the age range like i jumped
right into that kind of stuff so it just
yeah it's been it's been a slow
transition out so even
you know chad if any of y'all are like i
got something that's bothering me i got
something that's
that seems insurmountable it really
doesn't matter what the situation is you
can always find
something that's gonna help pull you out
of there and one of the best tips that i
ever got was
find a community connect with people
meet people you know
that's i probably would never be sitting
here if i had kept doing that or if i
had just you know never never looked
into something like that on her
recommendation so i'm very glad that
you know she didn't feed me any bs and
just told me to get out into the world
go at least try do something absolutely
oh no um so obviously yeah when
how much because you said growing up
like training's been part of your life
from 17 to 26 like
did not take long to go off and
obviously do many other things
how was twitch what got you into gaming
or have you been gamer all of your life
like i know you've got some history
there with like with some older stuff
but like how much time has there been
for that because it sounds like
your time was fairly allocated
previously yeah i mean there's always
time
in between when you're doing stuff and
there's a lot of down time that's where
a lot of the humor comes from even some
of the most
hardcore men and women i've ever worked
with are absolutely
hilarious just you have to be you if
you're in a really
high intense environment even you know
you look at military this that my dad my
dad is absolutely
hilarious that's where i get most of my
humor from he's super funny guy
man has 10 combat deployments under his
belt he spent a whole decade
in foreign countries fighting for you
know and just doing his thing
and he's absolutely hilarious he's got
his issues but
he just humor is one thing that i think
really
anybody no matter what the situation is
even outside of military combat anything
like that just people
gravitate towards because you have to do
something light-hearted or you go
freaking crazy crazy and gaming like
i played i grew up playstation you know
playing crash bandicoot and 64. you name
it game boy
you know pokemon's the big craze these
days it's resurging i'm like man
back in my day i was playing on a game
boy that didn't even have
color yeah baby black and green
man i'm telling you yeah it was
tell you you're playing underneath the
flashlights while you're
parents are driving on the highway and
you get to make a move every 30 seconds
because you're coming under one of the
lights i know both you know exactly
yes that's real road trip for sure yes
like i
and i grew up playing halo i played halo
with my little brother
you know all the time and just that
naturally
as soon as i heard that bungie's
developing a new ip
i was i was all in immediately i feel
like anybody that played halo
immediately made the transition into
destiny at least gave it a shot
yep absolutely a lot of beginnings for a
lot of people man
it's just so cool to see that that
transition and you kind of
approach destiny so you know we got to
ask those questions now
as far as the as far as destiny like we
know the halo
background right we get that so is it
that
simple master chief
titan was it just that synonymous you
just
that's the class that let's go we
punching things
like what was it at the character
selection screen talk to me
i feel like a lot of that influence came
from my dad and from those kind of
characters that you read about you know
i
i grew up in instead of my dad handed me
books on this that or the other he was
handing me books about leonidas and the
300. he was handing me the battle of the
monopoly he was handing me
the book of five rings like yeah he did
the whole
we were we were educated about
everything and you read about those kind
of
headstrong characters i've just always
gravitated toward them i loved
kratos god of war you're telling
[Laughter]
just like i love that kind of character
and just in games in general i like
playing characters that are a bit more
tanky somebody that's on the front lines
yeah i had that natural gravitation
toward it
yeah i i was this close i was this close
i remember
the fluffy dress and it was like i'm
sold yeah
i got two of y'all today it's gonna be
tough on me today
because i like y'all both i'm home
against two headstrong titans
right now it's so good
i'm sorry we got this we got it so you
know i got two brothers my older brother
really never got into gaming but my
little brother actually plays destiny
he's a warlock mate
and i haven't disowned him yet so that's
a little bit of something
but it's just it's nice that there was
something for everybody that was what
the difference was between halo and
destiny at launch
you play halo you play a master chief
even if you play arbiter and halo
2 it's the same character there's no
difference there
another titan question gotta file um
what is your favorite titan of
in law out of all the time what are your
favorites
man that's the question of the ages
right there i don't know
shacks just something about
jax yes batman yeah i feel like he's me
it is titan personified just like he's
got the
humor he's got the focus the fight the
fire he
i mean he's great but there's so many
great titan characters you look at saint
14 man
you're telling me seeing him pull a vex
out of a portal and beat him to death
with another vex was not some of the
coolest cinematic
moments we've ever had that's fantastic
like man just it was i was so good
and when i saw that i was like this is
exactly
what i imagined saint should be like
and they didn't disappoint well i
completely agree he always say the same
14
missions it was almost criminal you
couldn't replay them again oh
man it was so good it was so good
i mean as of all i mean i had to admit i
was i
i my inner titan came out there i was
like all right this is
the one we put the bubble up the one we
came out the pool like
everything and he was fighting with you
i think at one point
we tried to free him and you're free in
him and then you get stuck and he saves
you
yeah oh some of the best missions
yeah he's definitely there's no question
i know this is a tight knife gotta give
it back to e
but why do i feel titan means don't give
salad in much love talk to me about
saladin
he doesn't get really loving the game in
general yeah
but where we at what's up curious with
wood with a titan here
saladin just occasionally puts his like
witch's brew stew sitting up there at
the top for a week and then he bails
like
we had the rise of iron which honestly
he looked
his voice like the cinematic the wolves
the fire axe
dude looks like a beast and then that's
all we ever got and he comes and goes
every week but we've never had
any more expansion on him and it's
honestly
really sad because the actor who does
his voice does an amazing job
amazing job he's always like i had a
cool story for
now we know his like origins they went
through with the iron lords the fights
he's been through
his loss that he's been through all of
that stuff i mean you have
who's the cannot remember the girl in
uh right
never got to see much from her and just
she kind of wandered off and stuff like
so that always feels like it's not got
the justice and that's a whole
discussion for an entire podcast of like
how little has been done with iron
banner over the course of destiny 2 has
been really sad
i would love to see a lot more info
about salad and because i
live for banner like d1 banner
was my thing i loved it more than trials
like it was just
my thing i love the aesthetic the armor
everything about it speaks to me
in that just old school blood and honor
style
let's get this fight going kind of thing
i mean eat the axe
man i need to get one of those i'll buy
the equipment forge one myself if i
could like
man i'm telling you i was hoping that
middle tree sunbreaker would have that
axe instead of that hammer
that would have been the cool i'd never
hop off that class
perfect but yeah i would love to see the
lore expanded a bit on him instead of
him just
you know hey turn in your tokens here
here's the 48 stat roll booth
see you next week that's all he gets is
once a month hey here's four boundaries
for a couple pinnacles oh you don't need
pinnacles well
i'll see you next season that's that's
all he gets
um but yeah i wanted to ask you as well
some of what i saw you on twitter and i
gotta ask where it started
the bounty grind some of these like
weekly bounty tournaments that you would
put together this quick little video and
just like bam bam i'm like seeing
season rank like four five six hundred
just like where did you start
why did you start doing that because for
me i never even i've
i play a pretty good amount off and on i
have my ups and downs of course but it
was like
i don't get remotely that high in season
rank so it's like what
what about the bounty spoke to you and
also i noticed you haven't been doing
that as much which will kind of lead
into some other things but it's like
how did you get on that like level 600
boundary train like what did that to you
i'm curious
i had played the absolute heck
out of that season and gotten to like a
hundred and twenty i think really quick
within like the first
couple weeks two three weeks or
something like that the first go-around
just because i had a lot of time off at
the start of it
and i had a buddy of mine at this point
i was still playing on the xbox before
uh
i was on pc and he was like well what
season ranker is like 120 he said ah
only 120.
i heard only 120 and i was like all
right
the competitive side takes over next
week
we'll see who's higher because he was
like 119. we come back i hit like 156
he was like a buck 30. i was like all
right we'll see what we're at
next
i really did it just to shut them up but
then it became like
just it was interesting i had nothing
else going on that was like right when
a lot of the interesting stuff in the
world started to
kick off you know so we all had more
time the season got extended and i was
like the bungee number is
777. i'm at like 500 and something
the season's extended this is the only
chance
i'll probably have to hit that number
and i hit it the last
day what number two hit that was
777 and i still got it saved season of
the arrivals i could throw it on the
banner wear like a badge on
dude that's perfect that's the bungie
number two yeah
what else you got i mean that these
stories so amazing no i was like yeah
but before like we could sit here and
talk to you about yeah we could talk
about this nutrition your background
just being a beast but the world of
destiny in the past month has covered a
lot of things so
we don't have to spend as much time on
some of these but i do want to touch on
these topics because we haven't talked
in a month
yes so in the past month we have had
the donning event come to completion and
finish up and wrap up and we saw how
that ended
we have had obviously the twab
heard around the community this week
we've had stasis
making its run we've had trials come
back and kind of launch and adept
weapons
the state of like crucible of course
with beyond light
and sun setting so we can talk about all
that stuff i don't know if you guys have
a preference of an order because they
all have their own little stories do you
guys want to go chronological
or do you even have a preference or is
anything just like i want to talk about
this first
guest honor okay i'm sorry i feel like
one of the things we could probably get
out of the way a little quickly was the
c
the event and we've started to notice a
trend where i believe this is the second
event that we've had where more than
likely
if nothing was done to the progression
like the earn rates
how much we were supposed to have we
definitely would have failed at some
point
100 percent i mean yeah like there i
forget with the
man i really i'm struggling to remember
what the other
yeah um amazing just like yeah they
tuned
they had to i see i barely played that
season
um mostly for from time constraints but
that was a worthy right when trials came
back or disputing
all that that whole deal we have a
different wizard that season but
we were gonna hit those events man
nobody was doing them half the people
that were doing them didn't even know
how to do
it was god awful they tuned it we hit it
i honestly couldn't even tell you what
the reward was i don't really remember
it
right wasn't it that was the shotgun
yeah uh
and this one i mean i don't know if
it's unrealistic expectations of us or
if they're not
gauging how much community activity is
still like how many people are actively
engaging those kind of things in the
community but it's just been real
interesting to see that
we're you know we're like two for two
over here are we gonna get a third one
where they're like hey
the rate of uh warlock dust that you're
getting from killing stuff with nova
bomb is a little low we've upped it by
30 you know what i'm saying yeah
what do you think how did you guys
yeah i mean obviously i'm not the
biggest fan of
community driven goals
to dance some type of quest
you know to me from the start
systematically just you're putting way
too much
trust in the community to get that done
especially
there's unrest and they're not happy
so you know to me it's it's a little
toned especially when i feel like some
of the goals are
really high you know they really you
know these are some large you know
whatever four men what i'm making up
numbers but like four million
you know this cookies baked yeah
you know and it's just like okay you
really are banking on guardians to go
out here during
this level of a drought of content or
whatever people's frustration are
you know it's what i call it's like not
gauging the temperature of the room
yeah right that's so the fact that you
have to keep going back
and then stealth edit and then
boost up experience and boost up you
know cookie making and all this other
stuff it's
like okay you should have kind of
learned your lesson the last time so
to me i feel it's one of those things
where again seasonal content
they're trying to extend and stretch
stuff and they say these are these you
know
i've got the word i'm gonna use but
stuff to just kind of ease things along
cause you really don't have anything
substantial right now
and you're gonna just put this in as a
goal but the problem is the community is
kind of lashing back it it's it's almost
a joke
shout out to tassie because it's like yo
let's see if we fail it
let's not do that i mean that's that's
where we're at at this point is
at this point what's your incentive to
do it because bungie's at some point
just going to slap the 100
button on and be like good job you did
it even though we did the check mark for
the other 70
because we haven't actually failed one
there have been no consequences
it's just like an adult saying like hey
if you backed out again we're gonna
leave
and that's like the parent if they don't
actually at that moment get up and leave
the restaurant or leave their amusement
park and be like
if you don't follow through there are no
consequences to your actions and it's
like it's a bad analogy for a game
developer but also it's like when you're
saying hey we need you to make a million
cookies i don't know if it's a
million or a billion i forget the spirit
number it was a crazy ridiculous number
right but it was like when you're like
okay so same event we've had three years
in a row
rewards get to that one in a second uh
of both what you got from the weapons
and then also the rewards from the event
but yeah it's like how do they misjudge
that
hard they have to have like active
player numbers
and like number of cookies be like that
you could make
and then the worst part was like okay so
you need to make these things
if you i needed to go get like hey i
needed one fallen ingredient
do you have any idea how hard it was to
go get one in one
and how many cookies did you need to go
make and i'm just going holy
what like why was it so hard to get
stuff you should if you need all the
shower us in that stuff like you gotta
run around and make all these different
things that's fine but
i need ingredients from like shooting
things with auto rifles and swords and a
weird mix of stuff
but if i need to kill a fallen enemy
it's going to take me like five lost
sectors to get
one ethercane or whatever and i was like
there's no way i'm like i as soon as i
saw how slow that was i backed way off
because i was like it's gonna take way
too long to do anything
my boy kai boxer did the same thing he
actually pointed out to me
that they changed something in the
algorithm where last dawning he told me
because
i didn't pay that mind but he was really
frustrated he said what you said
he said that he whatever material he
said last year you would just shoot the
enemy or do that thing and it would be
an instant thing
yeah now it's almost like i don't want
to say a random but a couple of
percentage points it wasn't dropping
consistently per action
and he said yo he was frustrated so i
didn't even realize that during the
course of it but i was like wow
i was kind of like a stealth change you
know yeah they slowed
you had more blue ingredients than you
could ever know what to do with but the
green ones
like the race the enemy erased ones nah
fraction of what you would need on the
other side wow i didn't realize that
yeah
and then the other piece was the rewards
for the build and this is where
for me and this is where i'm going to
say a couple of my two cents on it is
expectations seem to be a major issue
for bungie setting what's coming
we have had so such an up and down as to
what is at the end of these dark tunnels
of community events we don't know what's
there we got a fell winter story quest
with
you know rasputin and the lore and fell
winter as
all that was a cool story mission but
granted it was that something that
nobody wanted to do
so you put something actually kind of
cool at the end of something somebody
doesn't want to do
this time around people didn't want to
bake cookies and then the event this
time was prisms and shards now for some
people
i will definitely say yo thank you for
the raid very much guys
um some people like newer players when
they logged in and the event finished
and they got a shard they're like cool
i don't have that many of these this
helped right but for the average player
or your dedicated ones who grinded stuff
out they're like i don't need another
shard this is not worth my time
they either have enough or they don't
care so there was a
the casual player is like cool i logged
in i got a shard but on the other side
why does it have to be the community
make a billion cookies
or spirit or whatever it was what if you
just logged in every week and as long as
you logged in once a week you would
progress the
your progression and the final week if
you logged in for the fourth or fifth
week of the donning you'd get your shard
just come be active every week it's not
that hard to log in once a week
and that way it's not on the community
or people like chevy who did
6969
and he's like i'm gonna stop there but i
was like that guy's doing
like the work for obviously like six
like tons of people
and that should not be that way
so yeah i was like just so i was like
yeah titan
what do you think on yeah i mean even
that was part of it you know the i
remember
speaking of ball the very first photo i
saw the first day
is oh my god there's a kinetic with
dragonfly
and i was like wow what i was like hold
up did i just read that
let me scroll back up and check this out
it's like they gave
cold front dragonfly i gotta go grind
for that like two days later
this is unintended it'll be changed
oh was just like it's like the community
was like
coming up a roller coaster and then we
just
uh stopped right back down
we never got over the hill and i i
remember seeing as soon as i saw that i
was like i gotta get on a grind and then
as soon as i saw it was changed
i was like well huge back to pvp
[Laughter]
oh you're right i mean that was my idea
i mean i'm a fusion guy too and they had
the the glacial classic
and i'm like it's it's cool we got here
until the paint job nice
yeah yeah like it's it's just there was
nothing
nothing that sang to me like i have to
have this or it has a really unique perk
or
you know that the conversation right now
is swaying heavy in the
sun setting and it's we all
heard that the man we're gonna be able
to bring out some hard
hitting crazy good weapons and then we
saw
temptations we saw falling guillotine
and every there was a talk of the town
man
everybody had to have them everybody
grinded their faces off
for him name another weapon that's come
out since then that's your next
falling guillotine that's your next
temptations
they're not like they're they're not
there
and then this time around what burned me
a lot was
avalanche yeah i am
so like that's just pisses me off
because
what did i have before in my avalanche
like i'm pulling it up right now i had
rampage
feeding frenzy ricochet rounds and then
i had medium zoom
like i had i'm good like i don't need
one
it gets sunset in season 11. we're in
season 12.
not even a season later a month later
i'm like yep it's back
um and okay do one great thing with
avalanche though
what i got the name right because my
damage feels like it's sliding down the
edge of a cliff when i use that thing i
feel like i could be using
let's take care of this the way the gods
intended
facts so it's like yeah the reissues and
we'll get more on that later but that
was
that was the other thing when i was like
hey and i had a
same thing with um i didn't get the
dragonfly which didn't matter obviously
but i have a pretty good um what is that
machine gun
yeah i have a pretty good old one of
those too that had kept i was like oh
this looks kind of cool i didn't delete
everything
because i had a dynamic sway reduction
feeding friends say range
accurized chamber compensator i'm like
cool nothing even close
and i'm just like and this is we we had
our sunsetting
whole thing before and in theory had
some potential but right now
it's a whole thing um it's like you said
with the
before we move on from the awards like
you you get everybody that gets that
little gold golf ball they're like man
this is great this is awesome
but those players that they're not
hurting for materials it's like i did
all this work
for nothing virtually nothing to show
for it
yep that's rough man it's a rough
position to be in
yeah it's like secret missions like the
zero hours the whispers the
even the hawkmoon stuff that like we
kind of understand but if the community
event is going to be like
hey if you log in every week or at the
end of the channel we're going to give
you some upgrade awards
and we're not going to make it crazy out
of reach that'd be one thing but if you
put this like
big giant thing i don't know which is
worse
what if it was like if it was a
cosmetics bear or a golf ball i'm not
sure i would have carried either way
because like we have so many cosmetic
ships and sparrows at this point i'm
like you only need so many i feel but
we know they're hiring but um yeah you
know we we we gotta get i know shout out
he's been harping this um you know it's
the investment right
it's the time investment and again just
like titan said like
you know when i heard about that cold
front i got so excited i'm like
a yo like you know i'm already thinking
about what my sales bills and
flows i could come up with and i'm like
okay i'm gonna get grinding and you know
when that was snatched away and it's
like okay that's a bug okay cool
you know glacial cab don't get me wrong
it is strong it is it's really good
you can do damage with it but like you
said it's just you know
you throw avalanche back in the mix and
we don't get in the sun setting it just
really didn't feel good you know what
i'm saying so
yeah they've they've got their work come
on that that's why i don't and what's
crazy dawn is one of my favorite events
you know i do actually like doing it
but it's like they've got their work cut
out forward especially with these events
especially with the time gaining
especially with the reissuing there's a
there's a lot they got to work on man
yeah community so
that one came and went and then the big
hubbub was
trials so two sides of that trials coin
we can see which one you guys want to
talk about first stasis
and a depth stuff which one do you guys
want to tackle first because they both
they both have uh a fun piece to them at
this point
let the guests decide i feel like the
adept weapons are probably
well it's i guess the the whole topic
will be as easy for us to cover as the
weapons were interesting
it just i mean it just
fell flat for me like you you get adept
range or a depth targeting or yeah you
know adapt this to depth that that
doesn't
make gun feel incredible
because if you take a god roll astro
horizon
a quick draw opening shot whatever it'll
slap people you take the adept version
out it'll slap people
the feel of the gun is almost completely
identical the arbitrary
hidden stats that you're gaining from
there don't impact
the flow or the gameplay enough that
it's noticeable to the average player
even to the higher up players if you
throw on an adept targeting modder you
get that plus
10 aim assist or something like that to
be honest it's fairly negligible
with the way a lot of this works with
controller mouse and keyboard what have
you
it just doesn't you can throw two
targeting mods on your helmet and get
basically that
and be good and have do you know more
aim down sight speed better handling
this that the other thing
i feel like what made the guns in d1
those adept versions so good is we had
kinetics with elements on we had weapons
that you
you used everywhere that even if you
weren't interested
in trials or pvp at all you saw that and
said i
have to have it i've got to go get it i
need to meet somebody i need to talk to
somebody
whatever get in the community get
somebody that can help me
hit that lighthouse and pick up that gun
and there's
just there's not one of those weapons
for me
that i'm like i gotta go get it it's
just
it's not it's not there fire brother
on fire i mean same thing and i forgot
about that because elemental primaries
at the time
was a trials kind of thing that kind of
it gave
you know benefit to a lot of those
weapons you know and
you know it's i'm in the same boat as
you you know the adept stuff
it's barely negligible shout out to cool
guy he had a great video and it was just
like
also i felt for the guys who who already
grinded and had like almost god roll
versions of astral horizon or
um
yeah and it's just like you know
every like i i get it now it's like
we're gonna i'm gonna touch on this
later too it's like
when you have the gar roll or something
and then they introduce this and then
you gotta hope to to get this thing back
or
get it again you know that was another
thing so you know and and the thing i
know he can't stand is the the ones the
mods that do like okay
you're gonna get this plus this but
minus this
yeah and it's just it don't feel good
right it don't necessarily feel good so
now you've got to make these other
type of decisions and um i guess my main
thing
right now was just like okay i wasn't
motivated because it was a
the same weapons again right so i really
wasn't and let's be real outside of
maybe
two or three yeah they're not
really meta weapons and they're not that
good
like what titan is saying to be playing
even in the pve
sandbox so it's like and the last point
is like
and you know i'ma keep stressing it
celerity should be intrinsically
involved
on the gun why is celebrity just running
around in the
loop pool you know saying messing up the
rest of the gun like how
that that one specifically because
they've seen cool guys a couple others
asked across probably too like big pvp
players who spend their time in that
playlist
far more than i do i'm not a pvp man by
any means but
celerity the only place it's ever going
to get used
trials elimination maybe survival
whatever the comp stuff is those are
really your only three i'm like
so if you take the time to go all the
way to the lighthouse you should have
something that benefits you in those
small circumstances where you're the
last person alive
it comes and otherwise you're wasting an
entire perk slide
and then the other piece that i heard
for a lot of people is
how many high-level pvp players again
speaking from other people's words not
mine
would prefer to have icarus grip almost
every other adept mod
period because so many people have
high level players the biggest thing
that will set them apart they have good
gun skill but the other piece is
mobility
the way they move their character around
the way they're floating in the air the
way they can
jump and hang in the air and hit those
shots airborne without icarus grip you
are
shooting you're trying to hit a barn and
you're almost going to miss
so if you don't have that second slot
which is what a lot of us thought it
might have been
you have to trade across grip for one of
these other mods and most of them aren't
going to do it anyway
so you can go range masterwork and you
can go adept range or you can go range
masterwork
get a decent roll and just go icarus
grip and be ten times better in the air
and that's one of those trades that's
like and this is for me as a pve player
i said it in chat and i was like
grandmaster nightfall rewards that are
coming out
you got palindrome you've got the swarm
and you've got
uh what is that freaking auto rifle
the one everybody liked shadow price i
think um yeah
they're going to be adept weapons so
some of these same adept mods are
probably going to be coming
but again grand masters for the people
who can run them all the time
they get all the exotics they get all
their rewards from them anyway
is a adept palindrome gonna set itself
apart any more than any of these other
ones some people really like the
palindrome i know people are excited
about that one specifically
but i was like to me is the grind to try
and get a god roll in a grand master
which unless you're god to your player
for most people they might ever get one
is that ever going to be worth it for
somebody and a lot of me says no
and these adept mods if they're going to
function the same way i'm like
strike exclusive rewards that are like
these slightly
smidgely better like masterwork adept
things
i'm already not excited about stuff that
isn't even here and i know i should
probably say
wait until it gets here but if it's just
like the trials chest
we kind of know what it's going to be
right no i mean this is
i understand the frustration you know i
think
the problem for me is when we went away
from pinnacles pinnacle stuff and
the pinnacle stuff added that chase it
added it made you jump in comp it made
you
you know grind for that luna and that
mountaintop or whatever it is in the
recluse
and you know for whatever reason they
don't want to seem to go
all the way guns blazing with this you
know
either unique perks or this really
hard-hitting exciting type of weapon
style
and i get it from a balance standpoint
but there's another part of me saying
well you introduce sun setting so
you're gonna get rid of it anyway so why
not i think we kind of have to go back
to it because it's like
did like titan said it best like plus 10
range ain't exciting
me it's just not it's just not like you
don't really
feel it you don't you know it it's it's
very
you know that's the thing man again
there's one side of the balance team
that is fighting against this
right but then you've got the sunset
team
whatever whoever's doing that and it's
just like these philosophies are not
mixing
and the problem is and we said it last
time we
we did last word was that even on the
armor side like
we introduced a gambit set oh crucible
set
you know i'm saying vanguard set and you
see this drab
outfit with just a color swap and i'm
like
i'm not grinding for that i'm not i'm
there's no incentive so
until they make the rewards
match the intensity or difficulty of the
activity
then i'm going to do it if until they do
that it's just like
they're still kind of throwing rocks
against the wall trying to not do
pinnacles
we kind of need the new vehicles let's
let's just get it we miss breakneck we
miss
you know all those cool little weapons
that we had in each
activity to make us stay in there and
and that's i think the fundamental issue
they're still
fighting themselves because they're
scared of balance
you know that that's what it feels like
to be but that's the problem sorry
i'll give it back to you in a second but
that was the the quote that i saw and
somebody posted it perfectly right
before the podcast
and it was the one literally from one of
the developers
and it basically says like hey you know
recluse crap on
everything in pve weapon sunsetting
means we can add more weapons that crap
on everything
and they just eventually fall behind in
power new weapons that can crap on
everything
we haven't seen those like we got a
a tame we got a beloved with a scarf
which some people are like
it's slightly different you're not
feeling your gucci and louis vuitton
lv on there come on i need i need the rv
on this guy
you're like
i don't know if you guys are big marvel
fans thank you guys
it reminded me of thor ragnarok when he
was like they'll know who you are and
then he pulls the scarf and goes
not like this
he's like no no yeah now you can't see
my face i'm not the beloved
i was like oh my god thanks
that's yeah like so the adept and it's
like and i'm not even the ones going for
it you take the dedicated players the
fallouts the cool guys the drew skis
like
basically you can take the entire bit of
like firing range that whole podcast
they are like very top-tier skilled they
break down and analyze weapons and stuff
they're all awesome they would all kick
the crap out of me in pvp
and i don't know how many of them are
that i've seen videos here and there
that are excited about this stuff either
and it's like i'm out of place is not a
pvp person
mm-hmm i have it's over there don't hate
my door dude hate your door
so it's like that was basically you
could have had beloved and it was doing
the same thing so yeah
yeah so yeah it's like their whole
they're worried about the power creep
but they promised with sun setting
the power creep would have some
flexibility because it would be
short-term
we'd get this chance to experiment with
hey this perk's really awesome it's
going to be gone in here
hey this pinnacle weapon's cool here
it's gonna be gone
like and we've got you got one weapon
your pursuit weapon and we're
potentially gonna get a pursuit weapon
every season but
does it really set itself apart at all
does it make you
like could you could is there anything
you can't do with probably another
weapon that you can do with that one
and it doesn't seem like that anymore
the raid at least has some unique perks
to it
what's up i know we've been in our
bungee bash fest
oh and believe me that's i knew this was
coming i had to say this
because um all right i'm gonna be real
with you i know
this is a very unpopular opinion i'm
about to say go for it and
for me right i know everybody's pissed
right now
we're gonna get into all the other stuff
that people rightfully pissed
for me again came back i was on pc i
came to xbox
you know game pass tons of people coming
to me
wanting to share but shout out for back
for daddy who's in here he's a big
sherpa in the clan
you know so i've been playing a lot of
this raid
the raid has really rejuvenated and kept
my love of the game because it's so good
and the reward systems and the way that
you get the spoils of war and then your
eyes tomorrow all the other stuff
so i just want to give them credit on
the raid because i feel the raid perks
and the augments
are really well done they are um
specific to
activities which i always wanted they've
got some things that stack
it's a really fun raid to run that's all
i wanted to give this top three for me
all the time i'm debating it now in my
head
i'm close to you titan i'm close it's
definitely tough
it is up there like there's no question
i probably got one little mini
picks because remember now we comparing
greatness greatness
it's great let's let's we know it's
great right so
i just i got a shot the raid weapons
amazing heritage trustee
the hand cannon yo
the ra i gotta give them what maybe all
the resources went to the raid because
the night
is popping like i haven't rated
this much since last wish like
i really rating out here you know what
i'm saying so i just wanted to i got to
give them that it is such a fun rate and
everyone's you know continuing to do it
as tomorrow is what it is but um yeah
that was pretty much i
just wanted to get that off i think most
people agree with you on that as well
dmg dylan posted something a while back
uh i think it was last week
he said what what's been your favorite
part of this season
and one person i think i saw one person
post
uh can i say the raid is part of my
favorite thing this season and he was
like yeah i mean
well it launched kind of alongside the
season and then
thousands of other comments came through
roland the raid the raid through eighth
eighth or eighth or eighth like just
relentlessly i think i went through
there
and i saw that comment so overly so i
can't remember a single other thing i
saw everybody agreed on one thing in the
community
every single person unanimously agreed
that that raid
was great and it is it's great the
even the aesthetic man you can't tell me
those guns aren't some of the sexiest
guns in the game
they take shaders better than anything
i've ever seen
they got the little leds they got a
little they got an apple like
feel too yo those choices fire bro even
the arm like
i can't believe it's pretty much
everything i like they
they they answered my rap to the machine
or issue either because i've always said
give me incentive to keep running this
now you got my sports war now you get
the chest you could bail okay i didn't
get this i didn't get that
like it's a lot going on and they really
nailed that you know what i'm saying
now season stuff
and that's the sad thing is like what
was how much was beyond light if you
bought it on your own 40.
the season was 10. the season this time
if you didn't buy the expansion pass the
season didn't come with beyond light
that season was truly separate if you
didn't buy the expand like the
yeah whatever deluxe yeah if you didn't
like it
bungie bad bungee on um no time to
explain
what mad people can't get it if you
didn't pre-order a specific way or a
deluxe version
like there's no way to get it i heard if
you don't
did it had to have gotten the uh the
deluxe yeah to get
no time yeah there's people that tell me
you i never got how did you get that and
i'm like yo i got it regular thinking
that that was just a normal thing
people don't have no time to explain i
did not know that yes
it is some real i've i don't say play
with but it
it's it's nice it's uh it's the best
it is arguably uh objectively the best
pulse in the game
right now even from like a ttk
standpoint it beats out pulses in its
arc type
so so you all know
that we got me she got me going on the
pc did you see what did you see what
clipper just put up for wha
oh oh i saw it i never got that that
joint when you never die before
shaq's going off yeah like i never got
the the ghost or whatever
the um no no that not the ghost that the
um seven kills without dying
no we got the we ran oh
damn yeah
before i was getting killed by it
because usually i'm a vigilance guy
yeah i was like damn i keep losing to
this one dude he got no time to explain
you know what let me dust it off for pvp
because i honestly thought it was going
to be good
because i thought i wasn't gonna be able
to proc the little ghost guy right
so it's a by the way that's easy to prop
in pvp but
two bursts headshot two pers headshot
boom you in the business you already
know the deal
so i jumped in there and i'm like oh my
god is
how they let me get away with this i was
like
this is the new dude like i'm like i
this i'm not coming off of this you know
it's that beast it's basically cold
denial with better accuracy more range
and
yeah yeah it it's a lot of people do not
have it bro
it's it's crazy what you're able to do
but sorry for the change i have no
no no that's obviously what i didn't
realize so cognito stacks with axel
just just throwing that out there
tempted to run
to be so toxic and get rid of the artist
bro run tickle fingers with this with
the oh what's that
get away from artists and just
really beat and go hide
[Music]
that might be my my real sweaty trial
bill to be annoying
like yeah i know i was thinking i was
like i just can't be that toxic just yet
but maybe under the right circumstance
push me so speaking is going to take a
ride on the dark side
pvp and balance and all that fun stuff
how do
you pvp heavy people feel about stasis
and i know we got some changes coming
but how has stasis been treating you
guys in the world of the crucible
huh titan first how stasis crucible feel
for you good bad hate it love it
i would tell you but i i got frozen 30
seconds ago let me i gotta i gotta hold
the button down and break out of this
real quick
[Laughter]
be like hold on a present okay stasis
you guys had nomad on a while back and i
know nomad pretty well
uh you know it's like you said earlier
being he has echoed it a lot throughout
his
twitter throughout he's constantly
talking about it on youtube
one of his best videos i think he ever
did he ran a trials card with patty
cakes and cami cakes
very high level players and he's a very
very good player i don't think he gives
himself enough credit
but he's really good at the game he
understands the mechanics and he
one of the things he said is that he was
slow to the fight in almost
everything i remember that video yep i
remember that
and that the the biggest difference
pre-stasis i mean it still is one of the
top pillars of what makes someone good
in pvp
is movement yes that you take a brand
new player and put up
against somebody else and there's
nothing they'll be able to do
no chance so it seems like
the only natural progression for destiny
as far as what else you could introduce
is something that's going to counter
that
and we got crowd control which
in its current iteration doesn't feel
incredible initially out of the gate i
knew going into it
they were they had everything over tuned
and they were going to let it be the
wild west for a month
and they did we all knew that's how they
would do it
and they said oh we rained in we rained
in warlocks right out of the gate uh
it's the fastest we've ever responded
something like man y'all had them
changes done four months ahead of time
don't
don't try and tell me that you didn't
already know
this was gonna be a little problematic
i'm glad y'all did it i'm glad y'all let
him go out there and slap for a while
but it's i figured before beyond light
that supers would be the primary source
by which you're completely immobilized
and everything else would be a slow
would be a disorient
something to that degree
yeah and it's really just not that
i mean you toss the grenade you could
pull somebody
eight miles out from behind a corner and
freeze it as
the glacial grenades i mean y'all been
how many times you've been glacier
shattered dive oh
yeah i had too many to count like that
where they just you know we
just heard this twap they're gonna rain
that one in and i think we all knew that
was gonna happen
i think even a lot of the top players
across the board i haven't seen one
person say oh this is ridiculous it's
fine
we all know that it's ridiculous if
you're just naive if you're
saying that wasn't real i've wiped whole
teams at the start of the game if you
spawn on twilight gap and you're a
hunter and you run 100 mobility
you can run right through the middle
throw a grenade shatter drive get six
kills if none of them ran
man it's and it's nasty and i the first
time i did it i literally
stood there and said this this is not
okay
and then that's the thing is like that
drives into
separating of sandboxes because they
nerfed here melee into the ever-loving
ground
they gave it back but is it back where
it was originally for you though
um nice good it's good it's good i mean
it's it's all it's like
80 percent back you know it's just maybe
a slight little rain drop off bubbles
it's not bad it's not that freeze like
the
the really immobilization yeah
just initially my first thought like
right when i logged onto my warlock and
i finished
that campaign because i play all three
classes even like pvp
i love warlock mobility top tree dawn
eyes
nothing feels as good as that when you
juke somebody and just blast them then
drop a dab on them when you when you
finish
it's this game over man there's just no
coming back from that
excellent but yeah i right when it
launched i was like all right i got a
build that's
a hundred strength i got double uh
melee induction on the the bond
i got claws of ahamkar on so i got two
freezes
i'm rocking monte carlo
i get half my melee back i was like
let's see
because i used to do that with top tree
dawn so you could get the double throw
yeah the fireballs
and a lot of people don't expect it's a
great one of the best range moves in pvp
and it just i think i had like a
a like a 52-0 game at the
first just i i was like you would
this is not what is happening like this
is not okay
pre-fired around the corner even tracks
a little bit like
i was just and i had my melee damn near
the entire
game almost the whole time i think i
shot my monte carlo like six times
mostly once or twice it was because
there was a dude in around the corner
who was afraid to come by and i was like
hey
come over here come over here come on
here
come shoot the guy in the dress i'm in
the middle shooting me and just i was
like
man this is not good like the
trials i knew immediately because we got
we were going to talk about it in trials
it's like it's such a hard counter and
the complete immobilization of another
player
in any game that you're playing is never
going to feel great you're just even if
your positioning was arguably
bad to some degree you at least got a
shot if you slide under somebody
you outmaneuver them a little bit you
slide into around a corner and get
frozen and a warlock dabs and then he
shoots you in the face with a shotgun
you're like well
i'm gonna alt f4 that one and go have a
good cry
i'm out and it just it changed the
sandbox so dramatically in such a short
win to a time that we saw the uproar
yep i mean both of you guys like here
like you said you're not super pvp but
i'm sure your twitter just had to be
oh i mean yeah a bunch of the destiny
community as i know exists usually
because i try and
look at as many people out there as i
can follow them you never know of course
podcast guests all that stuff
man my twitter feed was rough for a
little while there and i was just like
holy
everyone i mean there was a because
i'm trying to remember who was on the
podcast because it was uh the filler so
you got maru and nagi
and then you had tassie uh tony ill
physics who will get on here a little
bit later
nomad was on there and then you had uh
hotline so a couple pvp a couple pve
guys they were talking about just the
state of things
i was a great lesson between like where
things are at and stasis
and just like pde and that just builds
into more of like they were talking
about
the neglect of pvp like we're at a point
to where now i mean it's just becoming
more and more apparent of
the little love that pvp has right now
not one crucial map
period like travesty yeah and just like
even shaq's now getting a couple other
things and we'll talk about some of the
rewards that are coming but
that was the whole pve versus pvp some
people like oh it's a pve game and it's
like
it's pve i mean yeah there's a good pve
side to it but i can tell you the
longevity of the game usually survives
on the pvp
because that's the repeatable because
pvp is always something different
you can learn mechanics you can do raids
over and over you can sherpa people if
that's what you love to do
but for a lot of people the variety
comes in pvp and to
completely disregard that is not smart
because it is
trials is what kept this thing alive in
destiny 1 for one of the first times
during some of the droughts like pvp has
to be there
now granted do i wish there were two
separate sandboxes yes
i still wish that was a thing but
it's no it's just gonna say and then
stasis and it's just
the community over the course of like
the neglect in pvp
because i mean the whole twitter thing
it was like do you i mean you remember
tess he's saying
i do not feel valued as a pvp player and
he wrote that like five times
that was what did it and then tazzy was
like hey this is kind of a thing
not no he's like and i don't know if
this is the right way to say it not any
tasks he just didn't know and he's like
hey i was just wrong i didn't know who
it was and
this is like tony ill physics is
basically right he gives some of the
most constructive and has for years and
he's like finally it's just like
it's been years and i just don't feel
like i'm being heard yeah that that
wouldn't touch me bro
who was it that that also left that uh
evp
hush yeah you know
this
[Music]
you know i'll still find a way to get
some level of enjoyment when i do my
pinnacles
or you know sometimes i stay in the comp
a little extra when i'm in there i'm
having some fun and testing stuff out
but
yeah it's just we're just undervalued
man and
it's time i know we're gonna we're gonna
get to this tour but we're gonna talk
about
the comments they made there but i i
can't get mad at those people who say
y'all
enough is enough i don't care about what
i like you know i mean even then we had
yeah vixen on she's being you know like
like
epoxy yeah yeah like scrim queens and
you know that's what they do but it's
like
you know i try to be understanding and
respectful
for a team or studio you know based on
resources and all that
right i really do but again when we get
statements like
dude focus on pvp we get statements like
giles is back you know that and then you
get these results
and you don't feel valued and you know
we get it
we understand the majority of the
community is playing pve we understand
that
but it is so lacking it's such a
disparity
that i really feel for content creators
that that's their main
focus because they have been like
neglected children out here
and i really hope bungie you know
because we're gonna get to this
i got some stuff to say about what to
say about pvp here
yeah i'm holding it but yeah it's gonna
be a reckoning
you know people that the intensity level
is high
you know say the tolerance leverage is
low yeah
so um that kind of basically wraps us
into
i mean kind of what's been happening
over the course of the past few weeks
bungie had been quiet there was supposed
to be a swab last week that got delayed
probably still absorbing feedback trying
to get their hands wrapped around what
they're going to say
there's they literally have stated
there's four twabs they have probably
planned out the topics they're going to
cover
in these next four weeks and the first
one started
now the order that i want to cover this
swab with you guys is as positive as i
can first
to where obviously the big debate's
going to be it's i i literally recorded
about a 30 minute video about the 12
because i looked at it on stream live
some of my chat was in there
and i just literally went down the line
and i re-recorded it later
and i went positive first medium to
negative because i was like i don't want
to start the negative because the rest
is not going to get listened to you got
to start with something good so
i'm going to jump order around the twab
a little bit the main topics that they
wanted to cover on this one
there's going to be three more before
the next season of stuff
they said changes to vendors they said
sandbox tuning for hunter and titan's
next on the chopping block by the way so
don't get too worried you
you hunter people that are scared trust
me titan's just going to be the next one
up
yeah i think you know though why is
always it'll always delay what is
nerfing y'all
oh let's let them rock let's let them
it's all it's always a damn delay i
can't kiss you listen i had you on the
show
your damn titans every time y'all get
another free week to play
with you like
which one's usually the biggest offender
first not always but which one is the
biggest defender in stasis
in stasis we all know
it started with warlock
so they're going this time but i'm
saying although all the time no this
time stasis
was more data to determine no they don't
how well they don't damn go around the
map
yeah behemoth lasts for about six years
and
that's fine yeah believe me it's like
that's what i'm saying titans don't get
comfortable you're gonna come as quickly
as they can get to their data
so and by the way buncher if you're
watching me when i say
data i'm not trying to offend you it
just takes a while
when i know will you guys probably have
gut decisions and i wish sometimes
granted their gut decisions might be
extreme but sometimes i wish they would
be like
hey we think it could be this let us
throw
like a part of the nerve for part of the
change out there
let us keep testing and then we'll do a
second one i wish they would do
something like that
even to some platforms faster updates to
be like hey this is way out of whack
let's go
a little bit see how it feels nerf some
things a little bit as opposed to
do all the data knock it way down and
then bring it back up even later
like that doesn't they spin very very
get slaughtered in the tabloids man you
know they would oh
bungie puts out a half nerf a half buff
a half patch man they they just need
some test service that's what they need
roll that out quietly let some people
check it out
see how it's going crucible alongside
the launch
yeah yes how does crucible labs not have
another sandbox to be like hey you going
here this is the stuff we're thinking
about how does it feel
i feel like that wouldn't be that
difficult anyway so
first thing i want to talk about is the
update to vendors
they're focusing on a lot with shacks
and then
drifter's gonna get some of this so they
said first they're gonna be adding
two new unique weapon rewards to each of
the three playlist rituals so six total
these weapons are in addition to the
ones in the season of the hunt and
probably in the world loot pool
so just to see if i'm reading that right
i want to see what you guys say
what say the world loot pool is like
those 30 weapons we had in the world
loot pool
if you go into crucible it's 30 plus the
two crucible
unique ones is that how you guys read
that
i'm not sure i mean when they say
pursuit weapons pursuit means you know
something that you're gonna
aspire to go get something you're gonna
try and go get like i'm not sure if they
mean
it's going to be kind of like a ritual
they don't say pursuit though
they'll probably be called the front
cold and have a
fly dragon perk on it you know and it
may have a scarf on it i'm not sure
that sounds like it could be something
oh man
i'm not sure i i i really hope it is
something that's
in that drops more frequently you know
like a lot of the past weapons they
hit a certain point on the season pass
to start dropping in the playlist
and you see it fairly frequently um
you know i'd be cool with something like
that provided the roles
are interesting there's there's a lot of
good options there
we just have to it has to be worth my
time
because if i'm playing pvp i'm gonna get
a million of them passively
but i'm not gonna go do a thousand
strikes
when i don't enjoy doing them if there's
no reward there for me
like you can mindlessly grind strikes
all day i just
personally don't find it extremely
engaging
after the first five or so runs on one
you hear everything you need to hear all
the dialogue you
do everything you need to do you get to
the boss melt them in half a second and
you're done
if i'm gonna grind hundreds
thousands of those if there's a gun then
i'm like this is the role
i have got to have this is the one i'm
chasing if it's there
i'll go for it if it's there and gambit
i'll go for it destiny players are
ravenous
if you give us something to chase i will
move heaven and earth to go get it
110 we are very dedicated
i'm not sure if it's a good thing or a
bad thing but
by god we're doing it either way
with that if it's in a loophole with 30
other guns
and i just get the short end of the
stick with rng
and i see one of them in 50 crucible
games and it comes with hip fire grip
i'm chucking the controller across the
room that's somehow
get checked get your controller yeah you
need that room
that room man get it ready because i
think it's that roku
i think he's ordered something i think
it's gonna be a how it is now when we
play crucible and that stars in shadow
drop
you know what i'm saying and you know
crowd please to drop when you play
gambit like yes you know
i think that's exactly what they're
doing it's gonna be that
activity weapon that only pretty much
drops there continue
no it's a great pulse yeah it's got good
perks it is xeno's a good shotty but
they're not interesting
yeah i was like i was i think it was dcp
i was trying to catch up on
what everybody was saying for the
zeitgeist feel
and so they were the way they read is
like it says two
new unique weapons but i don't even know
if they knew it was new it's like it's
just two unique weapons or the
two more reissues coming in and it's
just gonna be a couple of the things
we've seen before but you only get him
in crucible it's like if it's just that
people are gonna lose it if you're like
oh i can only get crucible all i can
tell all of you right now
when go figure is reissued i'm going to
throw a
fit one hundred
percent your dad bod returns
what the hell be happy to you're dead
again after you had their god roll four
i had
two god rolls one had 40 000
kills that i use that if if when that
happens and i say win because sadly
now i expect it and we'll get to why if
i see that thing come back as like a
straight grind i'm just going to be like
what the f
yo it's crazy update
[Applause]
oh no that's i don't know if they could
do that the community might just like
shut it down
yeah they just call it the transit edge
and throw a scarf on it
hey yeah there you go
so we got you there's apparently a
couple unique weapons in the playlist
but it's
to my guess and i could be wrong but my
assumption is you have the world loot
pool for these things much less three
blue drops every time that nobody wants
um that's probably gonna be a mix of all
of that and then you add rng on top i
don't know how many of these we're gonna
see so that's one
we'll just have to see how that plays
out second starting in season 13 for
gambit and crucible
and in a future season strikes which
seems like it's going to take a little
bit more of a rehash
rank rewards will be visible at the
ritual vendor each season you'll be
greeted by a row of rewards progression
towards which will be earned
automatically as a complete relevant
playlist like valor
for example instead of having rank
rewards dropped automatically in your
loot stream they will now be picked up
as manual
manually from the vendor list we feel
this gives much better visibility into
what you'll be earning as you progress
and helps you make better choices
about where to spend your time now the
rewards
if you guys watch descendant nomads like
how to rehash pvp
a lot of this is right here so believe
me this is uh
looking very familiar so they said the
rewards for each level
rank four three upgrade modules rank
seven three enhancement course rank ten
first time it's a shader if you reset
your valor the next time
and any time after that it's three
enhancement course rank 13
two prisms rank 16 an emblem
and then again on future resets it's two
prisms the first time you reset it's a
shard
any time after that it's an exotic
my biggest issue is the last one and
i'll get back to that but i'll save my
thoughts
so again if you go scroll down they'll
show you a look of what it looks like
once you've reset you'll see
four you'll see upgrade modules cores
cores prisms prisms exotic
um that being said your crucible tokens
are useless
after this season so if you have 5 000
or more like i do or however many you
guys have
turn them in now because they are going
to be utterly useless so at least get
your legendaries
whatever you can get from them now
because they are going to serve you zero
good they will be junk
come season 13. so if you hear this now
turn them in now
use them up that being said thoughts
about this whole
change to the valor ranks is the main
place you're probably going to see this
infant meal probably work in a similar
fashion
guessing there any avenue that we've got
to get more more of anything
is a positive all i'm thinking is
more cores more prison more shards what
am i going to spend them on
where i i've got armors that's going to
be sunset that's god rolled
i got so it's i don't really have you
can get cores or a dime a dozen they're
dropping from package
rank-ups and turn-ins and and all that
stuff nowadays i got like 900 and
something cores i think i'm good there
like
yep for the average player that could be
pretty good because it's going to give
him another avenue for that
but man if you gave me the opportunity
to get a 60 plus stat roll
on rank 10 guaranteed and i could pick
the slot
i'm in if i have to reset and grind
another 20 levels to get a guaranteed
high stat roll
piece or uh or a great gun or one of
those
ritual pursuit weapons then i'm there
if giving us more materials when there's
a lack of loot
just all i'm doing is building up for
what
can't wait till which queen and gets
here
i'm gonna have so many shards and prisms
yo your shard game is is high i'm
questioning it i just shot
my pocket watching how's your shard game
oh yeah now they're
now i mean after you have any idea how
many tokens are turned in
how many legendaries i got to break down
talk to us
oh now we're doing good i think i'm
sitting at
like five or six thousand i started with
almost nothing at the beginning of the
season
it's not bad for for yeah it's been a
quick
quick climb to the mountain but and just
like what am i it's what am i going to
spend it on
what do i have that i that i need all of
those materials
for cognito thoughts i wish i wish i was
blessed as uh
because i am golf ball deficient i'll be
thirst for that like i get happy when
there's a double knight for reward or
something like that i get excited
look i i mean i'm going to get too crazy
i i like it i mean
you know obviously talk i think there's
a secret hidden
uh developer reason for my tinfoil along
with this one
i think cause wasn't this was it
tolkien's let's be real
was it tokens the old hustle
before the new expansion come out okay
leveling up
yeah that was still yeah filling the
leveling gaps
yeah this daddy budget we go get that
out i mean they told us they were trying
to fix it
yeah they did facebook they did already
yeah they did they did fix it they did
fix it all i'm saying is for me
you know with this actually i'm okay i'm
okay i'm not i didn't go crazy i wasn't
like oh this is
terrible whatever whatever you know
they're trying to streamline stuff
they're trying to give you um reward
stuff again for
you know i i know i know my man over
here he caked out with the shards but
for the rest of the world i hate that
you know i said i'm the dude that i do
kind of you know
exotic i mean i'll i like to any exotic
that i use
like religiously i mean shout out to my
bug eyes
warlock bugatti you know saying don
chorus my necrotic grips
you know things like that you know
anything that i use religiously i
feel i have to master it especially if
the stat rolls pretty solid
so that's where my materials go to my
favor by my phoenix protocol
my luna factions anything that i feel is
essential
i want maximum stability so that's why
my prisoners with charges have been
going when i finally do get a good roll
so for me and again i missed the upgrade
while
i oh you're yeah you're broke all the
time
this man runs that upgrade this man's
like eleven fifty one gotta upgrade
every piece of gear i got eleven
do it again because i i i got like
builds it and i got for each sub class
i'm like you're doing this while you
level you like you'll be middle of the
story campaign
hold on i just blew up upgraded modules
i used to do that
exactly i was guilty
what are you just wait like [ __ ] it
doesn't matter what you look like
you know it's save me order bits guys
all right let me i can put on the bottom
yeah make this walmart as he progresses
through the campaign and he's like i
don't look great i'm like dude just
wait till you level up i gotta be fly
every time like
drip can wait
100 all of it saved me and my resources
from that so i've started respecting
very far
stopped by the sauce exactly i got to be
nice with it but now all jokes as i stop
that but you know for me
you know this is cool you know the shard
now i will this is where i'm witty
where i didn't like everything i'm cool
with what i don't like is
why are you changing the shard to an
exotic
why why why why is this a problem to
keep
giving us a shard if we have the
dedication to keep playing it you're
still you're stealing my one main point
you never talk no 100 this was my big
thing in my videos like
hey getting shaders getting coors like
once you get the shader in the emblem
you're getting more of those cool
you give them one golf ball and then
you're going exotic engrams which does
two things
if you're gonna spend the time in
crucible to get the legend
you are not gonna break the economy
because the people who really want golf
balls grand master nightfalls are
throwing them at you you should get an
ascendant chart every single time
because
the amount of time it takes you to go
from zero to two thousand
is long enough right is in an insanely
much longer time period than anybody who
goes around a grandmaster
or even just a master with people who
they know the people who want
upgrade modules and can do it in groups
are going to be
just fine to go get as many as they want
and to fill up every character like
the zoe's the ob katie cats will have
three characters postmasters they'll
have 40 available at any point in time
because they're stacked
the guy the one guy like i just want to
play crucible i want to go through the
playlist and reset over and over and be
like
they can start getting those shards if
they want to play the game that way
and that goes back to my pvp argument
well where's the love like
pve has all these great sources double
knight four rewards and this and that
you get in charge and shower
if you're a crucible guy you're not
really getting it and a lot of guys
let's be real they're not doing trials
like that
you know what i'm saying to be getting
that and i don't even know the drop rate
on the shot so people got to tell me
who's going in the lighthouse in here
how many charges are they giving you
because i don't even know
i don't know you know what i'm saying
that's a [ __ ] one maybe two and
that's that's if you go
flawless all the way through like so i'm
not doing 30 flawless runs in a weekend
where is the pvp equivalent why are they
being penalized
for dedicated girls nightfalls
exactly that's what they're telling you
unfortunately the other side of this
that almost annoys me more
and i've been on this stupid train
forever the fact that you're like hey
after you do that
they are if exotics are not exotic
anymore
they're not you i was like now they have
special unique traits and stuff like
that but it's like we are
showered in so many places now oh yeah
we should like
exotics used to be rare and now that
they're like hey you get one golf ball
but we'll give you all the exotic
engrams that you can take and
like there's a point where yeah yeah
that was the other side of it but it was
like
the shards should have just leave it
just i was like if you can just take
that line change the exotic engram after
you read just
delete that and i'm kind of i'm good and
i'm like i'm
kind of cool with what they did like
that gives the solo grinder
who wants this to sit there and hey be
like i'm just sitting there i'm going
through netflix shows grinding out me
some crucible cool
got another reset got a golf ball cool
that gives somebody like that a chance
to have a fully masterwork set of armor
if they want to because yeah think about
when you're playing banner too
oh everybody have a little fun got a
little six to six bar doing it up
you know sometimes you get funny you
have fun that way and it's just like i
don't understand
logic that we just after that one reset
no more for you that's it you've had
your film yeah
one guy yeah and it's just like and
somebody in chat was like what if on a
high valor weekend i'm like
god forbid you actually reward your
players for spending time in the weekend
that you just admired
hey look at this crazy double and triple
valor you might have a very full
playlist
if that actually happens then what's
wrong with that
nothing i'm with you i bet you brother
so
i i like that's was a lot of people on
pvp were like
it's a step in the right direction right
but that's it it's the start of a step
yeah
it's a start but it was like but overall
i don't hate it
a couple things i would tweak but like
it's the beginning
so uh titan any more thoughts since
obviously we both went off the rails a
bit there
yeah i mean it's it's what you guys are
saying is just it's the sentiment that i
feel
every pvp player needs and even though
you say
we say things constantly in destiny like
the majority of people are playing pve
what do you think the reason for that is
is because that's where they're getting
everything they're they're going to pvp
and get smacked and get
nothing for it like man it sucks i'm
gonna go do patrols like
like it just y'all have got to keep
keep the changes coming give people a
reason to
jump into not just the base level of pvp
but from the bottom to the very tippy
top
give them something that they need that
they'll split their time there
for and you'll have more active players
and more
community interaction than you've ever
had
in destiny period
preach it brother preach it so that's
piece one
of zitwab number two
the changes to hunters they are under
the refinement for their stasis subclass
now before i get into this i want you
guys to pay attention to the numbers
and the percent change in some of these
numbers
to feel hey this is totally how it
should have been coming out of the gate
so some of you guys know what i mean
already so the short term goal
of the changes to hunters are to address
the outlier stasis abilities to keep
subclass assigned
subclass decision making interesting
they want to reduce the potency of
shatter dive
plus whisper fissures against guardians
which is good they're making that switch
to guardians only
that's a good thing uh going live it's
actually on tuesday so the 19th of
january
shatter dive now has damage falloff
versus unfrozen targets
okay max range damage reduced from 50
to five it's literally
one tenth that that that
that's not a drastic fix or anything
these are the numbers i'm talking about
so we'll keep them going damage
reduction
during ability reduced from 50 to 25
percent
literally cut that in half whisper
fissures reduce the min max now
basically the way this reads in case
you're wondering or in audio and haven't
read this thing yet they're going to
give the maximum amount of damage with a
range to the minimum amount of damage
and that's how these are going to read
so against non-super players
it was a max of 42 minimum of 22.
they're taking it from a max of 30 to a
minimum of
four so they're lowering that floor a
ton
same thing max the men damage for supers
was exactly the same
which is a problem and they're reducing
that to 16 to 2.
again we're talking about a tenth of
what it was
reduced detonation radius from players
from 10 to 9 meters
doesn't seem to do it much the whole
combination seems to be raining stuff in
quite a bit
but i just find it funny on some of
these
the scale of change like we're talking
like
a thousand percent change not like
yeah we give a little we're definitely
not in the bungee days of hey your auto
rifles from 20.1 to 20.2
we're in the exact opposite and very
drastic changes but that also makes you
wonder
how unbalanced it was
i don't think there's anybody in the pvp
community that thought
that this is fine you'll see what i just
posted in chat
oh yeah this is great everything's cool
i love getting shattered
from 30 meters away like you just the
fact that you could annihilate whole
teams or that you didn't even have to
freeze your target i could throw it
where i
knew someone was going to be in the
remote vicinity of
and shatter dive and still get the kill
if not kill them outright have them so
weak i get to
smile at them and they fall over i mean
it's
just it was ridiculous
and i mean and the ease of use
throw like there's zero down time i'm
not sure
one of those in there they talked about
the damage reduction that you have
was 50 percent when you're
shatter diving 50
i don't know if you guys saw i forgot
who who put the video out man i think uh
cool that cool guy talked about on
twitter the other day somebody made a
video
you could survive a direct hit from a
dawn blade
if you shatter dived the moment you were
hit
because you took 50 percent less damage
that is outrageous there's
nothing you should do outside of another
super
that should be able to just outright
survive
the strongest like it's just ridiculous
man
i think it was definitely well warranted
titans were next on the chopping block
oh one hundred percent yeah
that's right i deserve to say give me
just one second i'm going to switch
discord servers just to see if i can
even us out here
no worries yeah we'll try it okay keep
going
yeah keep going yeah it's just
it's like i said yeah they they launch
stuff
for new dlcs overtuned and they
mentioned that in one of the twabs
they said we we would prefer to
go guns blazing out of the gate and have
things get rained in
then have you guys start and go going
well this is whack you know these
imagine popping your super just having
nothing to show for in pvp even pve
you would feel like well stasis was dead
on arrival
and it's always better to have something
rained in
than it is to get buffed from nothing
because if it launches terrible
especially with how important it was
not from a community side of things but
also a business side of things for
bungie
launching this again with beyond light
and the whole
you know the next with they talked about
shadow or not shadow keep the
the witch queen that all the dlc's
coming out
they had to hit something on this one
and i feel like a lot of people
initially had
a lot of positive to say about stasis
specifically in pve
and it hit the ground running people
loved the abilities feel great the
sound design of stasis oh out of this
world
that shade minder has one of the most
unique
sounds and i hear that and the almost
like the
the after effects when you cast it it's
like sound echoing through a glacier
like it's it's ridiculous i hear that in
pvp and i know
immediately all right here's what i got
to deal with
but the yeah it's good they had to reign
that in because it became
so popular the drewski dunk the winnipeg
wombo the
the i mean it got named everything man
it just exploded literally
and was wiping guardians left and right
man it was
it's rough it's really rough out there
in pvp
look man man titan hit up all the major
points
you know we knew it was coming you know
i think you nailed it i think the best
point she said was that
vintage bunch right how many
we we've sat here we heard we when we
first saw the trailer of stasis
yeah me you sat here and said
man that look like it's gonna be busted
i think everybody did and then it lived
up to it
every subsequent last word goes hey how
you feeling about the trailer how you
feeling
yeah i don't know how i feel about that
and then we would debate enough to
freeze how long it's going to be who
who gets credit for the kid yeah were
you actually dead once you were frozen
all these debates is what was going to
happen
and not to buy all of them you know we
sat there we saw it we're like yeah this
it's gonna be busted
so i mean it it's it's like titan set
vintage bungee throw it out there
over tuned let it sit
get the data complete let us complain
then they come back and now they're
doing a reigning thing you know what i'm
saying
my only thing now is which i know we're
going to touch on
it's one thing to reign in but i'm not
gonna smell too much but
we got to bring others up yeah
that and we got to do because right now
it just feels for the bull i mean the
hunter thing was crazy that was i was
scared to death
running around doing all that stuff you
ain't beating that
you know i mean so that that had to get
addressed i know us we had to get y'all
coming soon my my main thing is just the
length of y'all think it's just
ridiculous
yeah crazy yeah but you know we get it
my main thing now is okay
what are we gonna do with everything
else and
i still struggle with the hold down
something to bust out
you know what i'm saying i got stasis
you know hold down this the
the butt and i don't know maybe it's me
i'm gonna ask you this titan like are
you breaking out i feel like i
i'll hit someone they break out quick
but mines is always a struggle to bust
i don't know like it's different on what
you're hit by i mean that's
if you hit by super it takes longer if
you hit by the warlock melee ability now
it's like a second and a half or less i
think 1.2
right um initially that was super
confusing to me i i was like like i'm
holding the pop my barricade basically
and use
you know that whole aspect of it i feel
like as soon as it hits you should maybe
a timer starts and it auto busts you out
of there and the damage that you took
they tuned that too
yeah it used to be when you broke out
you were dust you had
no health you even if you were in a
hundred resilience as a titan
you had like less than half it was just
ridiculous man
it's just in most cases in pvp if you
get frozen you're dead
it's very rare that i get frozen break
out kill my opponent usually it's if
they're trying to emote on me and
there's really nothing as satisfying as
that
you get somebody freezing you pop out
you smile and shotgun it like man that's
just
that's uh they quit the game moment
right there let's move on and
go back to fortnite never play destiny
again kind of moment
like first mistakes were made yeah the
last point i'll make is i really want to
get to the next couple of bullet points
because
to me it's more of i'm not so
anti-static as everyone else i still
think there needs to be
i still think there's problems don't get
me wrong but to me it's all about
counters gun play and i think shout out
to mercury he has something on it too
that i kind of agree with
reference to positioning movement stuff
like that but it's the next points that
we got to get into because
to me it's the way we're set up now
with you know just look at that build
titan was talking about
yeah melee monte carlo
claus albacore so he run it around
freeze central freeze like you don't say
so
literally i think that's to me again
we'll get the ability
versus gun play i think that to me is
more what's happening right now i think
when d2 vanilla came out it was like
gonna play gunpoint come play
rarely get abilities right now it's like
we got these crazy builds now that we
could just keep on
flowing and keep on getting recovery
keep getting you know whatever riffs or
whatever it is that you're using
and i think that is a little bit more
it's less about the gun play lately in
my opinion
and more about the abilities
so he can just say him let's just do it
here i was like you're just beating
around the bush at this point you may as
well just chop it down
improve pvp subclass usage and win rate
balance long time ago they had graphs of
like hey
how many wins does each subclass have
and they try and keep them fairly
balanced
right now i can tell you about well
how many do we have now 12 no 3
6 9 12. yeah you have 12 subclasses
or no whatever you have five between all
the characters
you have the three stasis subclasses you
have dawn blade you have spectroblades
those are like your ones that are good
the rest of them are probably sitting in
a dumpster somewhere
for your win rates for pvp generally
that's probably how you're feeling most
of the time
some people run around goof with other
stuff sure but especially the higher the
you know the more competitive anything
gets that's probably how that feels
they're trying to get that win rate of
all subclasses are via as are much more
viable options
so they're definitely getting there and
the other one you're definitely nailing
they want to review our ability to gun
play balance in pvp
and i think you said like mercury's on
firing range he said it too he's like
right now we're we are so far away from
gun play being the focus of the first
person shooter and it being ability play
and they say destiny is a game about
both explosive space magic moments
and intrinsically satisfying guns play
especially in our 3v3 playlist the
ability
the usage of abilities is climbed as we
introduce more and more ways to charge
them quickly
we're still in a very early discussions
but we're looking to restoring a better
balance
or proper gun play is rewarding and i'll
say it now and then i'll let you guys go
at it
it is a very delicate line for them to
walk to not
nerf ability regeneration rate into the
ground
but also make gun play be
make guns still be a viable part of the
equation of pvp
and again you can either have next to no
abilities that pop up every blue moon
which is like it felt like as you said
the start of d2
or now you literally have them every
seven seconds
yeah i mean let me let me jump on this
titan i definitely want to cheer
at this um yeah man it's this one i do
feel for them from a balance standpoint
because there is a part of me that when
you talk about that but i'm like man
that sounds fun
like whoa man like you getting the
melees you doing that like okay okay
you know but then it's like okay there's
another part of me that's just like man
you know um
you know i'm not really there's a part
of me as a pv player
i'm asking this question it's a part of
me as a pv player
that as far as why i love destiny right
i'm like mr anti-meta for the most part
i'll look at what the guns people are
using i look at always look at what i'm
getting killed by
right oh okay okay okay these guys
running around with this
okay cool and then i always try to find
a counter or something that maybe not
everyone's using is good but
is either effective a lot of people are
sleeping on it right
and i feel lately it's just been less of
that you know what i'm saying
the you know the only time i've really
discovered what we just talked about
earlier was the whole no time to explain
and i'm like oh this is this
is this you know kind of thing but
outside of that
it's really not not about the gunplay no
more especially with stasis
it's less about the gun players
especially with stations now you peek
around the corner frozen
oh boy you know what i'm saying like it
it it adds a whole different dynamic and
it i do
feel for them in this regard but i was
curious for you telling like how do you
feel in reference to the gun play
you know being less like where are you
at with that do you prefer like are you
like are you maybe like yo i'm having
fun with this build
i'm liking it like where are you at with
that hole
specifically this season it stings
more than ever because the guns
have never been in a more balanced state
i can really you can use any archetype
you get
120 hand cannons slap
140s slap pulses are great
scouts yeah they're there
we know those are the reasons you can
use fusions well you can snipers got
rained in a little bit but they're still
usable you just have to you know adjust
what you're doing like the gun play this
season
i feel like i can grab whatever i want
and succeed
good anything but
most of the builds i take into pvp
are ability focused and they have
there's two
instances this season and i wonder if
you guys know what they are before i
tell you
where they've done a good job of
balancing something that's really good
with the downside
you guys have any idea found something
that was very
good ice hold mantles
backrests you dodge you got a 20 second
cooldown
on that dodge even at a hundred mobility
backers is one of the best exotics
that's ever been introduced into the
game
i have broken so many people's ankles
with
that ah that mask it's ridiculous
phase clean through them turn around
headshot light it's just
it's nuts and it gives you higher
ability cool down so it gives you
there's give and take if some of these
abilities were tuned differently based
on their
lethality it's like ice hold mantles
people said
these things suck they're terrible
whatever on the titan man you could turn
into a walking tank you can take
so much damage with that you can dip out
of a fight you're losing
pop em turn the corner win the fight
like a cool guy
he put out an amazing video on him and
the put the potential of
the outplay you pop those though you get
a full over shield you get
i think it's an extra 200 health you
have a whole another guardian worth of
health on you
but you can't slide you can't run
exactly you know exactly what i'm
talking about like they just
that's such a good example of a way to
do it that i
don't ever feel like i'm not gonna use
these because of this
i'm willing to put up with that to have
backers in my back pocket
and otherwise if we still had nine
second
cooldown on hunter dodge like we did
pre beyond light and
backrest there'd be man it would
literally be battle of the teleport and
hunters
everywhere every nine seconds you'd have
hunters teleporting all over the map
it would be ridiculous man there's no
way
that's such a good if if they can do
that with something like that
why not do it with some abilities have
your
hundred percent strength affect this
melee by giving it a 32 second cooldown
but this melee by giving it a sec
60 second cooldown because the lethality
goes up or because you
shouldn't be able to spam something damn
it yeah
i feel like the reason they haven't gone
quite that route is all it's gonna lead
to is more of the people complaining
that this class has this this one
has this but you know just the back and
forth but i don't think that's really
going anywhere
it's it's a very very difficult
line to toad and uh nomad drewski they
had a video they did together where they
were just talking pvp and they talked
about how destiny
is more space magic now than it is
gunplay
yes and in those moments where you're
using space magic
it feels incredible i'll be completely
honest with both you i hate the behemoth
it's my least favorite class to play out
of all titan supers
i can't stand it i'm a middle tree
striker till i die
that slam i live for it man you spawn
you rock synthesips you run to the other
side you wipe the whole team
if you hit them and they're on that
point you got just enough time i live
for those moments bottom tree sunbreaker
do it all day
it actually destroys stasis yeah bottom
trees unbreaker for the with the wells
yeah there's so much
ability spam it's gonna be a hard l it's
like both of you said
how are you going to hit it so you don't
nerf abilities that we don't want to end
up in d1 yeah
or d2 we just don't that was like
that was awful man glad i
i knew it was awful when not to cut you
tighten but like i knew it was awful
when
as a warlock i had to throw on what is
it
not the the helmet that helps you
recharge your abilities a little faster
oh yeah yeah yeah whatever you want to
say
yeah you know what i'm talking about the
the big globe yeah yeah i was just like
come on man like am i ever going to get
my melee yeah
and that's the thing is like it's not
call of duty this is never going to be
pure gun play
period and that's like they are going to
be different games but as you said it's
like
i don't want to wait six years for a
melee because that's just boring
and then it's also the issue is like do
they is this is that where they steer
cooldowns maybe pvp does lean a little
more gun play but pve you get more space
magic
because if you're running around a pdp
strike and it takes you you get one
super a strike
that sucks that's what we had
no but it was like so that's the point
where they truly do need to start
splitting be like
hey you're cool down in x is this in
crucible
it's 2x like so there's got to be some
type of balance there and again we're
all saying we know the job's not going
to be easy to try and figure out
how to do this but
it is very it is leaning that way
just the way a lot of bungie course
corrections though it can't lean all the
way to one side
and then be slapped all the way to the
other side and over course corrected
because
you can't start a take slapper and then
going all the way down the road and just
no it's
so that's the hard part we know is going
to be a thing
i don't envy them on that that part is
difficult i'm very curious to see what
they come up with
and last point is all these bullets is
nice
when that's
because pvp now i got to hold their feet
to the fire
i'm not trusting that we're listening
with pvp i was very patient
i've been patient for over a year when
when when i need deadlines and
the season of this is when this is
coming out season of that is when we're
gonna do we we're gonna attack this
right i need some more tangible dates
if you don't want me to feel like you
know right-handed step child you want me
to feel like i'm not neglected
you gotta say it's cool that you got
mid-term goal and they said
that's cool on a bulletin board i need
some time
frames because this is this this
second-class citizen stuff
ain't it sorry
no i mean that's it's fair i mean i
think that's where a lot of the pvp
community
is at because there are people who truly
do really enjoy
pvp and destiny like some people like
listen to miss 5000 watts on dcp and
she's like she'll go to other games and
she's like it doesn't feel as good
yeah like i love destiny but when you're
like what's the point after a while
that's the other side like we lost how
many maps how many planets and you got
no new crucible maps
no new gambit maps one slash two strikes
but we got old
we're getting two new strikes but
they're not new they're d1 strikes
and this is gonna go into what's coming
next so this leads into
the final part and this is the one that
is causing most people to be like hey
some of these points on the twab are
okay kind of working i understand most
people
just throwing a fit and
justifiably most of the time so
uh the rewards area lead justin deset
i'm sorry i probably butchered that i
don't know how to say it
d-a-z-e-t so however you like to read
that in your head
uh basically they said they spoke about
some changes that were making to gear in
season 13 in response to some feedback
today we're going to briefly talk about
it
so first let's review a list of what
we'll see starting in season 13.
the first word of the first bullet
kills me i don't have to say anything
else and all it says is reissued
i don't have to say one two three four
five
six seven eight nine ten eleven bullet
points to know that this one's already
off to a bad start
so i'm gonna say some of this stuff and
then we're gonna go recap
because i have to get through it all
otherwise i'm going to stop somewhere in
the middle
everywhere read the scripture brother
i will read and then we will discuss
reissued dreaming city reverie dawn and
moon dream band armor
these will also drop with high stats
when earned and shattered thrown in pit
of heresy
the final chest and pitoversy will no
longer drop a fully mastered dream ban
armor piece
instead the dream bane armor piece will
drop with seven armor energy
and is guaranteed to drop with at least
plus 16 in two different stats with high
stats overall
dream bane class items will not drop
from the chest
reissued or weapons for dreaming city
with new perk pools waking vigils
sleepless vouch safe and retailed tail
dreaming city weapons that drop in the
shattered throne dungeon can roll with
perks that are unavailable from drops
with other
reasons reward sources words
reissued four weapons for the moon with
new perk pools premonition
heretic blasphemer and apostate weapons
of the dropping bit of arrows dungeon
can roll with perks that are unavailable
from drops
from other reward sources expanding lost
sector
legend and mass sector rotation to the
four moon lost sectors
all the k1 first thing i'll say is the
more lost sectors than legend
and master look like more locations for
those great cool totally
not a problem yep okay before i go for
it you guys are first one of you guys
take it because i'm gonna go
when i get to me you know what really
hurt me with that
is the very last day that retold
was usable i have been searching the
whole time
since forsaken launched for one roll on
retold
rifled barrel accurized rounds slide
shot
quick draw with range i got it the last
day that it was usable before it was
sunset
with beyond light the very last day
and i lit it dropped and i was like you
gotta be like i just
i almost had a heart attack i was like
why
why now and then i saw
that gun is coming back and i have that
one
sitting in my vault with
the perfect roll that it literally took
me
years to get and it
hurts i think i blacked out i dropped my
phone i went down to the garage
all right um i'm done it's
when you hear things like when we get
rid of the you know the recluse
dominated we can have recluses in the
future
and then we go we're getting the same
guns like the armor it's aesthetic it's
gonna drop high stat
it gives me a reason to do shattered
throne and pit
which are two of the greater content
pieces in the game i haven't run thrown
in
i don't know how long i would love to go
run that it's just a fun dungeon it's a
great piece of content
if i can get good armor cool i can throw
a
ornament shader on that and it could it
could look exactly the way i want it's
that's all arbitrary to me but
the weapons like it's even if they have
new perks which i know cackus posted a
a post that said back when we got
gnawing hunger you
everyone was saying they were cool if
stuff came back if it got
new perks or a change and i think they
said they're going to be doing that
but it just it feels like a kick in the
teeth because those could have come
forward and not had such that brunt of
you know that big loss we had for a very
little net gain
in weapons and they're your arsenal with
beyond light
and instead they're like well now
available next season
we've got a bus date 2.0 blasphemer 2.0
head back to your favorite vintage
dreaming city store and get you your
reed's old tail like
guys you killing me with this i
i have three separate bite of the foxes
in my fault from three different
seasons of iron banner one of them
sunset
the other one lasts till next season and
the next one is gonna last the next two
seasons and they all have almost the
same role
like i can't it makes me sick to look at
that in my vault
like i'm i'm not gonna go re i it's just
it's not gonna hold my attention to go
grind for those guns again
because unless they the perks are so
drastically different
that there's just one that stands out to
a major degree
i it's just it's not enough to hold me
it's not
not enough to pull me away from pvp
cognito
so i've been listening in the background
you know just saw the dudes drop
he keeping me up to date what's going on
in the world
can't be that bad cat can't be
i mean look i i read the thing this is
what i
this is my first first thought was okay
what are they trying to do here right
and the first thought is okay
this is a push to make shadow keep
and forsaken content relevant which
in theory right is supposed to be a good
thing right because these two
pieces of content are still in the game
and i have to admit it does not feel
good you have to
pay for them true but then for the most
part in the game
but some people have to pay for some
people don't so a lot of people had to
pay correct you're absolutely correct
all i'm saying is that in theory when i
first heard it i was like okay
i do like the idea that shadow
shattered throne pit of heresy this is
dungeon pinnacle good content is gonna
have
a reward source it is going to be worth
going because in my
opinion when i would be in let's say for
example
the moon and i'm up there doing um
altars of sorrow right it didn't feel
good
when whatever that shotgun is after i
was blasting whatever
right and it got the big um
you know it's sunset logo on it it drops
sunset right now yeah
literally how is that a thing right i
did tier
or whatever alter and here come your
sunset useless weapon thanks for playing
t
have a good night that didn't feel good
so in the
in the in this initial feeling was okay
i see what they're doing
however my issue is just like
titan's saying you know it does not
feel good when you have worked for god
roll weapons
right and you have it they're in your
vault
and the game is saying no you can't use
that go back out there
and go reground that is it's it's
disrespectful let's just call it what
it's disrespectful
to time investment now this is the
question i want to ask y'all
and i don't know how y'all feel about i
don't know if anybody's mentioned it and
i don't know i doubt i'm the first but
i'm just going to ask y'all
why don't they and if they're going to
do this right
why don't they say hey titan hey e
your night watch premonition we're
bumping that up in conjunction
with whatever the new thing is so i
would love that question right so
now the guy that grinded like tight he's
got that retold time
it's almost the same thing but i had it
a lot longer but i still have one
right because he's god well he's good
he's like yo i don't got a farm right
but let's just say he jumps in there and
then they added a perk or something that
he did like
okay i could do it but you know what i
still got my god it's not
useless so my thing is they should have
if
this is bad planning all the way around
because you said you were going to
sunset
how did you how did you not know like
when did this switch come to to
we're going to reissue all the time now
and it's it's now it's like halfway
issue half new halfway
this is not what you told us you told us
we're going to get something like titan
said better than recluse you get
tired of that you know boom and we we
let that rock
we said okay bungie we understand right
now it's like this is the plan like this
seems to be
what their version of reissue is
and it's it's not it man it's it's not
it and i hate to go crazy on them but
it's just like this
is i feel misled on that i feel i feel
like yo that's not
what the intentions of what you said
that this
thing was going to be no one wants to
look in their vote with
god roll versions of these same weapons
and say yeah i'm going to go back out
there
and grind because you put a chain
reaction on something and you can't go
back there grind and you put
you know fine all right cool for the
people who never got something good but
don't do that to the guys that like i
want to know programming
is there a way because they've done e
they've done it
with they're like yo we're going to
raise the capital rate armor up to 14
something right oh they could yeah they
they've definitely done that
they've done it so they can't see
somebody
somebody in the chat said the and i'm
gonna go i'll get to mine here in a
second but somebody in chat said the
main
reason why like because they told you it
was sunset
people cleared their vaults so now they
are pot committed to be like hey we told
you to delete it
some people kept it for nostalgia's sake
right titans probably got his because
like jesus i finally got it two years
later i'm gonna at least look at it in
my vault occasionally just because like
it's pretty even if i can't use it like
my go figure i didn't delete it
same principle and i have literally a
retail tail almost exactly like yours
titan so like we had the same ones
but that's the issue is they told you
this is not going to be a thing anymore
it won't be usable in
high-level things stuff like that if you
want to keep it from basic crucible you
can
but generally a lot of people got rid of
them
cleaned out their vaults got rid of
anything that was going to be sunset and
it's not a season later
yeah that some of these changes are
happening we're getting re-issues on
eight of these weapons
armor sets are getting now sunsetting
armor is
sun setting armor is dumb right now i'm
just gonna call that what it is let's go
let's get
it it's killing me man it's abs okay so
the biggest issue with armor i'm gonna
give a couple pieces one
transmog neck in season 14 is going to
make it even more useless
yeah because then you have your stats so
you can change the look however you want
to
all the time shaders armor whatever
you're just literally filling a stat
hole
the worst part is right now they've said
joe blackburn i've said this to more
people than i know
joe blackburn previously stated armors
are going to get some type of change
so it isn't just a replacement stat
every 12 months
that being said if you get a stat of arm
set of armor right now that you like in
season 12
you're done yeah period you're good for
12 months
armor 3.0 is probably going to come with
witch queen it's going to have
potentially different functionality
whatever it is we don't know if they're
going to retract anything but usually as
it goes the newer stuff has some
functionality
the old stuff doesn't so season 13 14
which i'm still guessing is going to be
vog
and 15 every armor drop in all of those
theoretically is useless
because it's probably going to get
deprecated or at least made useless
when armor 3. it may infuse longer but
armor 3.0 is gonna what
is going to be what they want you to get
into same way they've
started pushing you into armor 2.0 to be
like get rid of that old stuff
they're going to do the same thing again
so you have an armor set right now in
season 12 that will last through 15
keep it and then there's literally half
your character
what are you doing now you're just
infusing 50 points every season
just to get a number which also feels
crappy
because you now have you're just like
hey give me more content
don't raise the level there's no reason
to raise the level
at this point the whole seasonal that's
a whole podcast discussion in itself
get him going get him but that's
like that's the issue is like why are
those like some seasonal things to be
like hey we added new stuff for you
we didn't give you another level to
grind division when we added these
things to go grind for
we just said hey it is top tier stuff
you can go do it
now doing the whole like 50 power level
grind i really hope they review that at
some point
because that but when you add content
just to be like oh i got to grind it out
again got to grind
and it's the slow part of the grind that
nobody likes because then you're back
doing strikes and crucible and gambit
and stuff like that why do they do it
for player treadmill use over and i i
get why they're trying to keep you doing
it
but seven years later this is starting
to feel really really bad
direction this season because we do have
uh
you can play and you can get powerful
drops
yeah that is pinnacle drops or whatever
every so often but
tired man i'm i'm right there with you
it's so
i'm so tired of doing that like i just i
can't be
i don't think i have a single character
right now that's 1260 or whatever
i've only i've only played my titan i
have not touched the other two
because i don't care i have not touched
the other two because i don't want to
grind them up literally what i can do
i've done this from a hunter because
usually i'll bounce between warlock and
titan
literally at the end of every season
i'll go grab a couple sets of armor from
the season pass and they're high enough
yeah all i ever do and i just don't care
and it's
i play with my titan enough i get to
experience the hawkmoon the raid all
i get to experience all the content the
raid is fantastic
but doing that grind on a second
character doing that grind on a third
character for
every season that treadmill i'm just
shutting it off and i'm gonna go hit
another piece of equipment like i'm good
i i don't fee all it is is an arbitrary
number
right i don't ever get to see stuff get
higher numbers do more damage and feel
more powerful basically
all you are is this arbitrary number yet
they play with that number however they
oh grandmaster you're weak
nightfalls you might be okay raids you
could be good and then you'll make it
you know you'll turn it into a chump you
can die in a patrol though
like the idea of your power level is
kind of like it's not like there's a
point where you're like hey i can
basically smash all this stuff by look
do you never feel that in this game
no that's a shame we've all we've we've
been beating that drum for the longest
being you so it's like yeah like
you know i i miss d1
i'm going to say age of triumph era one
of them eras where we went back in them
old rage
and i felt like a god up in it
i was like oh atheon where you at you
didn't say like oh just absolutely
you smoked him for that armor absolutely
i was bullying people on the playground
pushing kids out i was i was
ready so just yeah man it's just
you know i i i just wish you still felt
like that especially
again with as much as i've unlike you
two i've been playing a lot and a lot of
it is because the xbox community is
giving destiny a chance because of game
pass
yeah so i'm sherpering so many people
these days right and it's just
putting them through it and then i do
feel like i'm like if i'm helping
someone in a 12 20 or whatever it is and
i'm 12
75 12 80 i should be i shouldn't be
getting killed by
really anything like it should be taking
a while for me to i don't i don't feel
those levels of power so
yeah you know it's definitely it's
definitely an issue
um you know this right here man you know
the arm
i'm with you i was like so i was gonna
say i was getting back about i was like
i didn't even get to the 12. get your
point yeah get your boy get your point
off the law sector is great
cool um the stuff about the dungeons
giving you a reason to go run it i
support
that the issue is why did they have to
figure it out in the first place
yeah you have you still have content
that you pay for
which has already got a disjointed story
if you start forsaken and
spoiler alert you see kade die and
you're a new player and you're like what
the hell
who is that guy why is he so important
there's people who have zero attachment
to him and they start for a second he
dies in your first mission
you're like okay i know that guy died
why well i have no emotion
zero so then they don't understand crow
either
why that's a big deal they see that so
like that whole piece is there
now do i enjoy shadow throwing a bit of
heresy you know dungeons are one of my
favorite things
dungeons secret missions some of the
best stuff the final chest not dropping
fully mass or dream bane armor
i kind of hate that that's going away
for good yeah
every it doesn't have to do it all the
time but have a chance that every so
often in some activities
be it flawless trials be it the raid be
it you finish the dungeon
especially if you do it slow solo or
flawless
give you like okay what if it was you
had to do it flawless for a mess like
dude
i would sure i would go for a flawless
run
for a masterwork that's a different
challenge
for skill and then so like i would like
to see that sometimes maybe not all the
time but some variation
now the dream band armor going up to
seven armor energy we already joked how
useless cores are
that's all they're giving you is all i
used to ever take is my armor to seven
because i was never going to spend
prisms or cores i'll take anything to
seven
because i have like 900 cores to throw
at them so i'm like
that's cute now high stat rules if it's
like 65 with 2 and plus 16s
you might get some of those nice
distributions 16 and like 16 recovery 60
whatever
like those are those could be good and
getting rid of the class item is good
or figure out how to make class items
viable that's a completely different
issue
but those are one thing
retail tail exact same thing i'm looking
at it right now
i've got a snapshot quick draw accurized
rounds
rifled barrel range masterwork i have 96
range on my retooled tail
light just felt good
i do not want to try and get another one
because i got lucky to get that one i
got it fairly early on
vouchsafe scout rifle i had the curated
100 no i did
sleepless the rocket there are two
rocket launchers in here rockets suck
right now it's terrible so it better be
a meta
if you don't make rock it's good there's
okay now we're down to six
uh and i can only picture somebody like
drewski
who grinded the ever loving crap out of
uh altars of sorrow for a good apostate
the amount of time i remember people
grinding for some of those roles at
arthurs of sorrow that thing takes a
while there's no way to make it go
faster
and the amount of people that finally
got one of those
it in december 10th it was gone february
10th it will be back like
three months you just don't get to use
it and then you gotta go grind it again
go for it cause you're you're mr dungeon
you're the lord of dutch
yeah well yeah i like them yes
get a lot of solo done just got to give
credit where credit is due but um
my question like how do you feel about
does the at least the you know the perks
that are unavailable
only from those does that excite you for
the only dungeon perks
you could only get certain perks there
does that excite you for
not much okay theoretically but it also
depends on what perks
if you're just like killing wind chain
reaction and thresh are only in there
versus unrelenting and a couple others i
don't give a crap
that's not gonna make it worthwhile now
if you're gonna take reconstruction
recombination put some raid level perks
in there
that's at least something but still the
fact that the retold tail is a gun
already have
and then if i go grind through there and
it's just the fact that you're playing
with so much rng
for two years some of the stuff has been
in the game one year for moon
two years for the dreaming city and yeah
i
trust me i enjoy the dungeons and having
a reason for
some people to do it is there but a
reason for me to go earn a gun i already
had for two years
that i just couldn't use it for three
years and i gotta go get it again
that feels bad i mean as you said this
that's rough this
is not it i i was gonna die
on the hill of sunsetting but the idea
is you get
better things you get you know these
pursuit weapons that are cool and all
this stuff like
at this point sun setting has been done
next to almost wrong
you're you're losing the so much in the
destiny content vault
you got rid of two destination two
expansions worth of armor and weapons
and you sunset him
to three months later bring half of that
stuff back
much less the stuff that's in the vault
but this you i mean
how how did it make it through like
production
choices to say hey here's an expansion
somebody can theoretically still go buy
it whether it's on sale not they can go
buy forsaken
they get a gun it's useless they can't
literally take a gun
that they got in their story go to
europa and it's
you can't use it you literally can't
take it to a planet
yeah that i think to me this is just the
band-aid for that
that's what i think this is uh it
literally feels that cause i remember it
just felt bad i was just like why did
you know
but again like you said you know like
like how was this not
daughter ahead of time i was just not i
hate you know look i'm always pro
developer i always you know try to get
respect but it's like
i just don't understand how they put
themselves in this kind of position
with reissuing and with sunsetting
because at the end of the day it's like
can't just take take take take take
all these weapons all this stuff out the
pool
and then you're giving us half of stuff
we already had about
and then you kind of said we're going to
be getting new stuff and we're not
really outside of what the europa
weapons i would say
we got europa and we got season in the
hunt this time and the rosary
on the raid that those were the joints
and i'm saying and it's just like
there's still not enough in the pool and
look the
reason why people are frustrated is
because we said okay
beyond like we're going to give you a
little pack because this is the first
you just took away a chunk
it's the first season of introducing
things back now we're coming up on this
next season of whatever it's going to be
called
and people start seeing that old mixtape
stuff again
they don't feel good when you start
seeing the old joints of old albums keep
coming
back and now your stuff is useless and
it just it don't
feel good havoc actually said something
chat he said fell winters is better than
retold
and here's one thing somebody in chat
said to me as well fell winters is
supposed to be on the kiosk next month
yeah can't fellow winters also get
sunset at the end of next season
yep so like it's gonna go in the kiosk
for three months
or is that gonna get rid like pushed
forward
like that was one i didn't even think
like that's gonna go in the kiosk for
three months what if somebody grinds out
one of those exotic ciphers
buys it gets like what are the what is
your um
what's the raid reward currency spoils
yeah the spoils somebody it's not cheap
to buy those things in there
somebody grinds out a lot of spoils and
they get it for two months who's like
at that point as well you take a gun
like fell winners that was a quest item
and again now if their issue fell
winners like oh my god people are going
to lose them like
that type of stuff but that is at this
point what i'm expecting
i just expect to see everything round
too and i'm like
the the goodwill that destiny had
is really low right now for what the
future holds like
yeah for me right now i'm looking as far
as which queen and between here and
there
i just want to experience the story
right and you guys said like the gun
play
in crucible right now feels very
balanced and good
i mean titan you were saying you can
almost take anything in here the story
beats like
the stuff with crow getting him free
from spider
and then you've got whatever we're gonna
have yeah
it's like that oh that immersion
breaking moment when you free him and
then you go right back in the spot get
the hell out of there my god
leave that immersion breaking freedom
yeah just leave dude
like you know they're just making him
out to be like any other gamer it's like
saying hey covet's over and all the
gamers open their front door and go all
right
back inside to do the raid
[Laughter]
ain't going anywhere
that's one area they show a cinema with
you leaving with this man
leaving
turn off the xbox crow it's time to go
play outside with your friends and he's
like nah nah
i got one more i gotta get this roll i
gotta get this wrong
i'm staying in here anywhere else like
you could have put him in a cave you
could have plopped him into the
cosmodrome i don't care where you put
him
that is the one like the discussion's
cool you freedom i want anything in this
room i want him
you get him put him somewhere else that
is
one of the biggest missed opportunities
with the story they've had in a long
time is to not
move him just he's don't go to the tower
because obviously that's going to be a
whole
video whenever that happens anywhere
else anywhere else
somewhere even who said he got to go
back and pack
i'm dead
he's got a pack for like a month
apparently to get out of there
can't can't forget his settings it's
funny you bring up the story beats
because like that
that's the part of the pve for me
that is the most drawing for me
and personally speaking from beyond
light
that's the part that fell the flattest
for me
for one particular aspect we and i know
this is kind of away from the
the convo a little bit but shadow keep
we get introduced
to the pyramid on the moon and you walk
up on that sucker and it purposefully
slows you down you can't run you can't
sprint you walk up and you see it's been
there the whole time
the big bad we've been told is creeping
in
has been here watching us ready
the whole time it's almost like that
that moment you meet harbinger and mass
effect
and you have that that talk and it's so
quotable and it's a two-minute
conversation
he says your words are as empty as your
future
and your confidence is born of ignorance
i haven't played this by the way
oh yeah because he's going to do this
he's going to do the trilogy though
yeah he won't catch any of that yeah i'm
waiting for the remaster
the remaster
like you just meet this enemy that you
feel is so insurmountable
and then beyond light we're supposed to
be
we have our interaction with them our
first stasis and it's like he's like
we show up and he's like hey hey bro you
like ice listen
listen i know that light stuff is
cooling off but check this out
trust me it's gonna be awesome which is
like okay we're getting it we're we're
getting eustasis a little bit
but you know you're the whole time your
ghost is saying
you know i'm worried you're gonna get
corrupted i'm worried this i'm worried
that
but you're worried without cause because
we never
do anything that shows that
let's say you take out one of aramis's
lieutenants
and your ghost is questioning them about
aramis
and you draw your weapon and you put
them down
execute one of the lieutenants right in
front of your ghost while he was talking
to it
tell me you wouldn't be like oh damn man
that just got
dark like my guardian where did that
come from like i didn't even make that
choice
like he just he just smoked that [ __ ]
like what happened
if we'd have had a moment like that or
you know you could hear that
the little stasis crystals talking to
you in the background there was
something
that made me feel like man my guardian
is going down a path that we've never
seen him go down
good point i feel like it would have hit
a lot
a lot heavier for me instead we got the
side
story with another another
kell another one of them that just it it
fell
flat for me and i'm hoping that with
the witch queen they they've been
teasing this so long
this has been one of the biggest bads
throughout all the lore
period right when she shows up she
better
show up and wreck shop
we better not just be like okay she's a
pushover we beat her in 12 hours in a
campaign
i want this to be something that's i
mean one of my favorite things about
you you mentioned one of the little
questions you asked me
was one of your some of your favorite
times in destiny your favorite moments
in destiny
taking king because when we defeat oryx
and find out
that you if you really want to go beat
him
hop yourself in that raid with five
other people and go kill him
i was like oh i'm in it let's go let's
as i'll spend as much time as i have to
learn to
to take this fool down who
shows that strength at the beginning by
annihilating
an entire fleet like it wasn't
anything for him
i really hope we get some serious
serious story beats and
they get away from some of the you know
it's like the
the stuff with the crow i'm all for it
this season yeah i think it's very
interesting
it's been really cool to see you know
even like the
the community reaction to how he's
changed
yeah was completely the opposite that i
thought most people are like
he's the greatest he has to be protected
at all costs now because he's like a
brand new guardian yeah
he's a man had a bucket with toilet
paper by the cosmodrome
my man just got his first apartment
outside the common drum over here
he's he's living it he's sitting there
but he's living he's on his own he's
branching out
i completely like for me i think it was
the acting for
elsie and anna i enjoyed a lot of that
as opposed to the darkness because
going through the law sector seeing what
else he went through having clovis
be the tie into the raid was cool and i
think
that should have been the play because
about to go
there you took my point like and we may
have said this before
on the podcast too i don't honestly
remember but it's like the darkness as
you said like zavala's like oh you're
not gonna use that right
he like i mean come on even zavala is
like hey you're not gonna use darkness
anymore
you still had never a question later the
ghost
there's one point where the ghost is
like i'm with you through like i'm
having issues i'm him i'm
like i'm sorry i doubted you like there
was a little bit of that but as you said
if there was a moment where like
what if you just were like as you said
uncontrollable
pieces like the moment when one of the
best moments of destiny 2
was in the red war campaign where we
lost our powers and we had to walk slow
the dramatic nature of being basically a
broken guardian
with no power on the brink of
death
that was one of those rare moments if
you had an extreme other side where the
darkness
almost possesses us to do something like
it's almost pulling your gun and you
can't control it or something and it's
trying to
use you as a bit of a puppet as opposed
to just like
hey here's some ice use it like that for
me i totally i'm i'm with you on that
one justin for like the darkness to be
this
thing and that's why it's like the whole
piece of garden of salvation saying
hey is it is it like were your salvation
like
we don't quite know what that means but
to be a bit are they good are they bad
right there didn't feel like there was
that much to
embracing the darkness
ain't got a chance bro this wouldn't be
a fight
no we're your salvation you you don't
have a choice we're
here this is what's gonna happen and
then it was just
like all right
you nailed it you nailed it bro because
that part fell flat for me too because
like you said
shadow keep it was built up as the big
evil like you said that's been lurking
that's behind the scenes you know when
that would felt slow going around it we
didn't know what's going on
this starts you know elsie's pushing us
in that direction
but there's not this besides your ghost
whining every once in a while
there's no real internal struggle with
you you're like i got new toys i got i
could do this
it's like that's it and you just you've
completely embraced it
there's no internal conflict to me like
he said the best parts of it were
narrative wise
were i i like the lc basically the
strange like to me
she saved it she's a great voice actress
yeah you know the lc
the anna relationship and i actually was
more in tune with clovis like
clovis is what got me excited and yeah i
like the
what is it the simulation i like how he
be talking his talk to you like
he's a twisted dad he is messed up dude
i like hearing his voice i like hearing
his voice during the raid
you filthy intruder oh you think this is
the great you know i love that
that that sci mad scientist talk
and yeah i'm a little disappointed this
is where i take a little bit of decent
quick because deep socrates is amazing
i'm tired i i wish it wasn't taniks was
the book oh yeah no i mean that's
it's such a there's probably laura that
explains why he's there
and i just haven't looked into it but
like
i was hoping it was the random shadow
kell as opposed to
yeah like they may they may have some
bigger plan for clovis now
but it did feel just so art like aatrax
was like
okay you're in her in here you got this
like fallen who combined with exo
technology in the darkness and he's like
he's a badass now cool and then we're
fighting
you know wheelchair tannics like
floating like
yeah yeah like just floating around like
uh grandpa tannics yeah
i was like you just got like i mean but
it was like that's what he
was and it was just like it was it did
seem arbitrary because
eight tracks fit really well
like i didn't say it's just weird
yeah i wasn't happy to see tatix again
like i said the fight itself is cool the
encounter is cool
it's just him like you know i was i've
been getting attached to clovis
in general just his stuff and you know
especially when you do the lament
right you do the lament quest i thought
that was great
here and then you learn about you know
all that you know i'm saying so
that's why i was hoping it was going so
i was a little disappointed with that
but yeah i'm with you i'm with you guys
overall like
there was some missteps a little bit
with though and we all know
aaron is ain't dead that's the other
thing oh yeah she's just frozen up there
yep yeah so that that's that but yeah i
mean that's they said hold on shout out
to
he said the point of tanks is because he
represents immortality but it's not
clear in d2
you have to pay co-attention to team
well i just it just it didn't hit for me
bro i mean
it very male well it will be explained
well in the law great
but playing it and seeing
tanix the remix it just ain't hit for me
as you know this epic moment as if we
were fighting or
fighting you know rage should be more
like a self-contained story it plays out
like a story i mean it really does the
whole way through if clovis had been
there at the end i would have been
elated to see could you imagine
like the remember how you do lament you
got the big head version like could you
imagine like a boss robotic
you know so crazy it would have been
crazy to be like
you even have banshee as literally a
copy of his consciousness that's been
cleared so many times
so he's like somewhere in there like you
could have had like big clovis who we
woke up
you could have theoretically had another
one in there that would have just
fit i'm with you it would have fit more
protect the station you know
he was doing his little dark magic and
now he got too far with it we got to
stop him yeah
but i digress but yeah i was like so in
the grand scheme
for me like the story has cool points
and i like what like
crow's got some cool beats to it like
anna and elsie and clove it's like
there are some cool interactions
happening we had season up like the
little ships on the wall and all that
stuff happening
fall into we still don't know what all
is happening there and it feels like we
just lost some planets so it's like
they're doing this long drawn-out story
and it's like for me the way sun setting
the uselessness of armor at this point
for me i really
honestly my play time over the next few
seasons
is looking minimal enough just to see
like story beats through
maybe experience like get an exotic that
comes in
see these little bits but like doing the
crazy grinds and stuff it feels like
it's going to be less
because being as the re-issues are and i
know they're building up the reward team
and they're trying but it just feels
like
my eyes are on witch queen and between
now and then
i'm just gonna see what's the the light
stuff in between to see what gets us
there
and i think that's where i'm at and it's
like i hate to be at that place but it
feels like that's definitely where i am
especially when i've been playing stuff
like
hades and demon souls and stuff like
that and i'm like that crap feels
amazing
and there's so many other things in my
backlog that i'm like guess this is the
time
until they figure out what they're gonna
do and it's okay i just wanna get
invested again man
i want to get to the point where when i
come home i'm like i
i gotta log in and get my time in
and i really i want that from a story
and a game play perspective man like
when you asked it was funny your
questions it just got me thinking when
you asked like in the
what's some of my favorite series where
gears of war was one that popped up
and i don't know either you guys play
gears oh yeah
he's played a lot more i played five
only so i missed a lot of the pre
i played every single one yeah so like
the the first couple gears games you're
playing through you get you got marcus
you got dom and i played those games
with my little brother and you know
cognito you play through
and we're playing co-op and then we get
to the point where oh boy dom
man that's one of the best moments in
all the game and he
he makes that sacrifice i literally
watched
my little brother right next like
crumble he's like he got
so emotionally invested in this
character and i'm like bro
he's like he's it's done i want to get
to that point with destiny where i'm
just like
man i i need to feel that again for my
love and destiny to be
a hundred percent just back in it
i feel you brother we could only hope
you know just
you know i just try to are you guys
hopeful for the future you you say hope
and that seems to be in short supply on
twitter
i mean listen we've been through this
before i
to me it's it's this cyclical thing with
destiny
i'm so used to it now it's just they
always
you know make stub their own triple once
they hit the
hit the rake and hit them in the face
and yeah and then
they do something amazing and then
you're back in again and just at this
point it feels like it's the
it's the longest since the amazing that
we've had forsaken taking king
huge turnaround this time as we're
so much farther away as this is four and
we are potentially waiting till year
five that's a long time for us to
hit that moment again now granted
do i think they can do something awesome
it's i think it's possible i don't know
where their focus is at within the
studio i don't know how much matters
for unit development sources i don't
know if it's even got the majority at
this point
destiny is can i put out something
that makes us money with
microtransactions some season passes
and trickles this along if maybe their
focus is on
it i can't tell where their focus is
because it feels like the re i know
they're hiring a lot of people
i know justin throw or whatever not the
right person i can tell you that's not
the right guy
justin i don't know his name he was the
one saying we're trying to build up the
rewards team
or joe blackburn was saying that and
i know that what they want to get to i
think and a lot of us have seen
potential in this for a while
but i know the fatigue is setting in for
people like me for some of you guys
seven years into this one
and now as we're at the point we've been
doing this for we're in year four of
destiny 2
and you're telling me we're just getting
more of the same
it's it's hard yeah it's like it's hard
and the hope at this point my hope is
for something
farther away because i feel like what
needs to change is not small
i guess it's the best way i can say it
they can't be fixed overnight and i get
that
but that just means i'm going to spend
my time other places
while they do work on the stuff that i
can hope for
that's literally well said well said
that's literally where i'm at i'm
i'm at the point now where the the
change that needs to come in my opinion
is going to be expansion level change as
opposed to seasonal
season of this change you know what i'm
saying it's going to be incremental and
as we talk about incremental changes and
things going on
it's time to get back out there get back
in shape y'all y'all know what it is man
y'all been
in the crib covert has been getting a
hold of everybody in this pandemic
but we hear the last word right ty we we
we got to promote this fitness thing man
don't you agree
don't you agree we really literally
that's the form look at the
look at the consistency in those reps
i can't even i can't see his face but i
feel the breathing being
breathing look look at this man look at
this level that yeah
the man is out here giving y'all game
on what you need to be doing when you're
stuck at home
doing the pit oh said fred oh he's got
the water there
oh it's on now now we got the push-ups
on deck you know what i'm saying what
are we doing we're doing this
unfair my push-up forms nothing on these
other diamonds we're doing the jumping
jack what are we doing
we're going to show off on them or we're
just going to keep it basic we're going
to keep making all right so we're going
to keep it basic
look at that level of form look at the
consistency
tight shoulders tight yes
good arch in the back legs together
you can bring that chin up just a little
bit man
just a bit don't look down when you're
doing raps chat
close that windpipe you ain't got oxygen
coming through trust me it's terrible
i've seen it
because black out under a squat rack
back out right thanks facts man look man
he's been going a long
time the crowd
they are relentless they want the
sit-ups that now we're getting the
reverse angle so let's
see now here we go here we go here we go
do you do you see the the concentration
the tension
oh with the rays
oh that's crazy that's crazy getting
that lower abdomen going let's go
game on fleek you ain't my guy i knew i
was in the right place
i knew when the last word
hit me up this was the place to be
this is where you gotta be man you
you're supposed to content
where are you gonna get this one
okay here we go this is just showing off
getting them tries engaged let's
see he's like stop it okay okay all
right your first chat
i can respect that i can respect it he
said he's gonna hurt too many people in
the gym
that was a good learning tool titan that
was right like because if
you pull something and then you say you
know what let me switch to something
else because we're not gonna try to you
know we keep the ego
out of this right telling you man
and that short intermission was
sponsored by advanced gg
advanced gg link in the description for
your discount code today
the cheetah is back i haven't seen that
red face in a long time look at that
look at that oh man this is a good day
chad you guys are relatively impeccable
form eb i'm proud of you i'm proud of
you brother proud of you man thank you
it was irl titan improved i'll take that
one
you get it from the titan you're
official you're officially
see that's what we missed man we even do
2021
through this this took off now we now
it's official it has begun
i'm just gonna go sit over there and do
my clothes out with a wall set or
something like what the hell
no doubt man i got that that's the same
thing he didn't
wrapped it up real real well there okay
all right so that's been it i'm just
kidding
no doubt you're gonna do it at least try
and do it right
shout the black wig he said destiny's
proven one thing it is what it is point
blank same combos every year same issue
i'm with you back wings i'm witch i
don't even fight them i don't even get
mad
anymore i just sit there and say okay
this is what y'all doing
stuff i'm interested in i'll log in if
i'm not
i got all this backlogger games i got my
man titan playing red dead right now
i'm going through a backlog when my raid
team comes asked me to jump in i said
yeah man i'll help you guys whatever you
need
any of my sherpas i help out but you
know i'm i'm not going to allow it
to stress me but i do feel for the
content creators who all they do is
produce destiny content
this is going to be a tough stretch and
people are going to have to make
adjustments you know what i'm saying
that's that's my final point
just you're going to have to make
adjustments to really you know diversify
the channel and do other things
because if it's going to continue like
that then for sure you got to do it
shout out to forte out here
thank you very much sir appreciate the
love oh
oh well yeah i was like i'm the same way
it's like i'm playing hades demon souls
working on the spider-man dlc to play
miles morales
zach like i made a list of games that's
like
stupidly long backlogged that i didn't
even play from
like last year maybe two horizon zero
dawn before the second one
oh uh death stranding got an i got a new
graphics card i'm gonna go enjoy all
these pretty new games
so shout out falling over just gotta uh
when they do it right you know we still
gonna be playing we're still gonna be
checking in you know what i'm saying
it's just it
is what it is until we get the bigger
change that we want
well that's all i got uh titan if you
want to
kind of let them know where they can
find you if you want to drop your only
fan's link this is that time
i don't know if i could drop the link
just yet i'm waiting for a real
i mean first of all i gotta get approval
from the misses
yeah i'm gonna make sure that's always
all good factual but i i can't just be
dropping the willingness
of a quick day job and i gotta worry
about getting fired i'm telling you i'm
done
i can't just be dropping it out of
nowhere but one thing i did want to say
before we head out here is that
you know there's a lot of talk even with
us talking about fitness with us talking
about
gaming whatever like it's been a rough
year for everybody
2020 was really rough 2020 is not their
2021 is
not looking a whole lot better
and if you're doing something if you're
playing something if you're doing
something that's stressing you out
that's really screwing
with your mental health don't be afraid
to branch out
i saw a tweet from emtash he he switched
to
gentian and he lost 50
000 subscribers in a very short period
of time but he
gained 250 000
if you're looking to do something
different if you if you're thinking
about
getting interested in your health go to
the gym you might
fall in love with it and never look back
read
write whatever you got to do just find
something else fitness is not just
physical you got to focus on your mental
health as well because
i wouldn't be able to do this as long as
i have done it
if i didn't focus on my mental health if
i had
never gotten into these communities i'm
not sure i would even still
be here today i wouldn't be sitting here
right now
talking to these two wonderful gentlemen
who invited me on today
thank you sir take care of yourselves
take care of each other
and you can find me at only fans forward
slash
we'll have to edit that in post don't
worry about it you can find me at the
irl
titan on twitter or miles underscore
muscle
on instagram hit me up whenever i'm
always down to answer any questions
fitness gaming whatever if you're gonna
ask for the only fans link
do it in the dms
slide ever so quietly into those dms
with lube and it's been a genuine
pleasure gentlemen
jesus oh my god
he always lashes me for jumping out of
fire that's just me when you're not
watching that's all
oh you have to do it it's late that's
right
me after dark yeah not quite the same
gotta keep it clean to the public thank
you both for having me on it's been a
great pleasure
sitting here with both of y'all
seriously it's been a pleasure as well i
knew we'd have a blast and we definitely
did
um cognito what do you got to wrap it up
and we will tie a bow on this episode
yeah man again salute to the titan for
pulling up man long overdue i'm glad he
was able to make it
i know we've been getting this uh
cooking trying to get a cooking for a
while so it's got to watch it worked out
good to be back you know i'm saying good
to be back doing it i missed last word
it
felt weird being off so long
and not but obviously not through
circumstances we can control but the
internet gods have blessed us
and we are back but yeah man y'all know
me at lord cognito on twitter
follow me if you want and um our iron
law podcast
every sunday's the lord's day 1 p.m
eastern we should have some cool guests
in the realm talking about gaming we
will have dreamcast guy
and hulk oh man so those will be the two
we're gonna talk about all the stuff
going on in the gaming industry star
wars game from bethesda
division twos massive leaving and making
uh what you call star wars open war yeah
what does that say for division oh boy i
don't know about the three now
it's like it's done yeah that might be a
rizzat
you know so we got that yeah with just a
lot of stuff going on in the game
so check us out 1pm eastern you catch
that on youtube iron lords podcast
or on twitch if you want to catch us
there and of course it is great to be
back on the last word oh last thing
lawrencegaming.net man please
if you guys see those articles the
retweets the shares
all that really helps a great little
team of writers that we got
passion project by gamers so really
appreciate the support
so what's it giving that night and of
course the last word about me
cheetah back out here giving y'all that
fitness giving all that destiny
knowledge
still going i'm gonna still say one of
the best you don't like what i see
[Laughter]
humbly don't know about us
we we enjoy our podcast here and we
thank each and every one of you for
being here
the love today that for the channel by
the way thank you guys so much
appreciate all of that
um thank you guys so much um
for kicking off the year uh titan sir it
has been an honor and a pleasure
and believe me we had a blast you are
welcome back pretty much any time
because
yeah we apparently can kick it we just
got to clear that schedule for you get
your workouts in and you are good
uh and then for me you guys know as we
talked about today there will be some
destiny sprinkled in there will be some
other things covered
uh if you guys haven't watched my twitch
streams you know i've been having some
fun with some other stuff
working on spider-man to get to miles
morales right now which is like my next
beat
yeah i'm going through the dlc's because
i never did those i did one of them
about you know three hours so quick
little stream segment and then miles
morales work on that one so
a lot of fun stuff in between and as
titan said in the times that we're in
right now
especially in what's going on in capital
what's been going on in the world the
last six months so many things in this
world
are tense and not in a good spot and
people are not treating each other very
well if you want that escape
make sure it's fun make sure you're
enjoying your time and what you're doing
because if you're not find something
else because it is not worth it right
now
to do something that you find for us
just step away find any other things
it is the time to make your time that
you spend on you
worth it so that being said for episode
132 thank you guys january 15th titan
cognito and all of us here at the last
word campfire
thank you guys very much we will see you
guys next week i think it's going to be
a morning show next week
so if you made it to this far we got
cloud plays coming on for now we're
going to go raid fallout plays
to give him a little love so thank you
guys very much
indeed so for this episode it has been
the last word